Und schon jemand da.
Und sind tatsächlich schon welche da.
Der kleine Isamstatter Void Danny Facegesicht hat so eine super Name, Alter.
Ne, ich bin nicht, aber ich bin gerade aufgestanden, ich bin nicht krank.
Erstmal.
Mr. Hustlers.
Windows 10 Update Assistant is already running.
Windows, warum sagst du mir das jetzt?
Auf meinem zweiten Rechner.
Warum? Ich habe überhaupt nichts angeklickt.
Was interessiert mich, ob der Windows 10 Update Assistant already running ist?
Ist mir doch scheißegal.
Aber wenn ich sowas hier schon sehe, kann man nicht hier irgendwie...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich will es nicht adden.
Ich will sagen, dass ich von ihm nichts sehen will.
Geht nicht.
Muss man sich zu einloggen, oder?
Warum kann ich das nicht ignoren und eingeloggt?
Ich kann mir Alexi Baxi nicht angucken, da kriege ich Zustände irgendwie.
Gucken wir Videos, ja was haben wir jeden Sonntag.
Sonntag und ein bisschen schwätzen.
Der Sibaro ist am Start.
Gleich mal schön bannen.
Erstmal schön direkt den Bann verteilen, gleich am Morgen, so muss das sein.
Der Sibaro, danke schön für sieben Monate in Folge.
Mein Twitch hat es übrigens immer noch nicht geschafft.
Nicht geschafft.
Die Vorschau so zu aktualisieren, dass ich online bin.
Also wir müssen erst mal kurz warten, bis Twitch das auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
Nee, ich bin nicht krank, ich weiß auch nicht.
Es ist ein bisschen immer...
Aber mir tut es schon zwei Wochen ein bisschen im Hals irgendwie weh, habe ich euch jetzt...
War ja letzte... war vor zwei Wochen ja noch schlimmer.
Geht es eigentlich wieder.
Aber wirklich krank geworden bin ich nicht komisch.
Normalerweise habe ich Halsweh und dann ist zwei Tage Halsweh und dann bin ich krank.
Aber diesmal ist es irgendwie einfach nur Halsweh.
Was auch immer.
What happened to Stadia?
Haben wir das schon geguckt?
Wenn nicht, gucken wir uns das an.
Weil Stadia hat es voll verschissen, Alter.
Ich meine, wenn ich sowas... ihr kennt mich ja, ne?
Ich bestelle mir ja fast jeden Mist.
Aber wenn ich was abbestelle, das heißt schon was.
Ich bin gerade im Labor.
Schöne Versuche am Sonntag.
Was machst du Sonntagsmorgens im Labor?
Na gut, wenn es dir Spaß macht.
Ich meine, ich mache auch Sonntagssachen, die mir Spaß machen.
Jeder was auf was er gerne macht, ne?
Chat, ich sehe, dass du nicht so viel Zeit hast.
Ja, ja.
Chat, ich sehe euch jetzt mal kurz nicht.
Ich muss jetzt meinen Chat mal aktualisieren, weil Twitch selbst nicht aktualisiert.
Man muss es nur sagen, jetzt hat er es hingekriegt.
Ist geil, oder?
Hauptsache mal geflamed.
Hauptsache mal geflamed und schon funktioniert das Ganze.
Nice!
Der neue Edge-Browser ist draußen, ja.
Und wisst ihr, was das Witzige daran ist?
Bevor der Edge-Browser rausgekommen ist,
ähm,
hat Microsoft noch ein...
Browser-Update-Blockpack rausgebracht.
Also sprich, wenn man jetzt wahnsinniger Microsoft-Edge-Fan ist,
und man möchte nicht, dass sein Edge geupgradet wird,
kann man dann einen Edge-Upgrade-Blocker installieren.
So einen Stuss gibt es nur unter Windows.
Das ist echt so eine typische Microsoft-Geschichte.
Der Hype-Train kommt.
Alter, was will Twitch eigentlich?
Hahaha.
Du hast nur wenig Zeit, um exklusive Emotes zu verdienen.
Oh mein Gott, Twitch!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Mehr das Gamma-Train, hä?
Vor allem, warum kriege ich die Werbung,
dass ich mich selbst abonnieren soll?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Hype-Train Level 1.
Abonniere, schenke oder verwende Bits, um die nächste Stufe zu erreichen.
Nur 94%, Leute!
Monka Shake!
Was gibt es denn für exklusive Emotes?
Irgendwelche komischen Vögel, was juckt mich das denn?
Magst du Vogel, Alter?
Haha, ich kann mich an das Comment erinnern, ey.
Das Scam-Train, genau.
Darf ich das überhaupt sagen?
Und es ist direkt hier.
Toss. Weiß ich nicht.
Ob man was Negatives über Twitch sagen darf als Twitch-Partner?
Ich weiß ja nichts Negatives.
Hype-Train Beste, Twitch Beste.
Twitch, größer Mixer, alles Beste.
Amazon Beste.
Stellsor, 5 Monate Dankeschön.
Oh, der Hype-Train ist bei 100%.
Siehste, siehste?
Amazon, Amazon, ähm...
Big Brain hat gezogen.
5 Monate, im fünften Monat.
Dankeschön, Herr Stellsor.
Easy.
Du schmeißt Deepin wieder runter, weil es nicht Multiscreen-kompatibel ist.
Ja, da hast du halt so die schönen üblichen Probleme, die man unter Linux hat.
Das liegt nicht unbedingt an Deepin.
Das liegt generell an Linux auf dem Desktop.
Die haben...
Wisst ihr, kennt ihr diese, ähm...
Diese 10%...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es 10% regelt, wie man das nennt.
Beim...
Wir machen jetzt mal geile Stonks-Grafik.
Also, ne?
Wenn man hier, wenn man hier sowas hat, wie, wie, ähm...
Huge...
Huge Craft gibt es jetzt, Leute, ja?
Also, das hier ist...
Ähm...
Ist im Prinzip, ist im Prinzip egal.
Das hier, das hier ist Zeit.
Zeit.
Ja?
Und das ist hier quasi so...
Ne, ne, warte mal.
Also, ja, genau.
Fertig, Fertigstellungsprozent.
So, und dann geht das so, dass, ähm...
Dass man quasi erstmal sooo relativ hoch geht.
So, und dann braucht man quasi für die letzten 10% irgendwie ganz lang.
Ah.
Und, äh...
Das so, also quasi für die letzten, für die letzten 10% braucht man irgendwie so lang wie für den Rest.
Also, huge, huge Stonks-Grafik, ich weiß.
Ähm...
Haben wir, haben wir den, haben wir den Typ eigentlich im, im Memeboard?
Den brauchen wir ab und zu mal.
Hypetrain Level 2.
Der Skamar-Strain läuft weiter.
Stonks, da brauchen wir jetzt...
Da brauchen wir erst, erst recht das richtige, richtige Bild für.
Stonks.
Wo ist es hier?
Ah, den brauchen wir.
Den brauchen wir.
Stonks-Man.
Äh...
Den können wir gebrauchen, den können wir auch für, für den Hypetrain verwenden.
Da geht's...
Huge.
Funktioniert.
Perfekt.
Ähm...
Genau.
So.
Also, da.
Weiß ich, ob ihr das kennt.
Also quasi, dass du für die letzten 10%, ähm...
Wie schaut's mit den neuen Emotes aus?
Stonks.
Haha.
So.
Und...
Wie bin ich...
Wie, Leute, wie bin ich da jetzt drauf gekommen?
Ich müsste jetzt mal 2 Minuten zurückspulen, äh, zurückspulen, was ich gesagt hab.
Ähm...
Helft mir mal, Chat.
Wie bin ich da drauf gekommen?
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Chat.
Ach so.
Wegen Linux auf dem Desktop.
Genau.
Ha.
Linux.
Das ist das neue Testament.
Da kenn ich aus.
Genau.
Und so ungefähr ist es auch mit Linux auf dem Desktop so.
Die sind, die sind relativ gut.
Die sind, die sind relativ, relativ schnell sind die da hier hingekommen.
Ja.
Also sprich, dass grafische Ausgaben funktioniert, dass alles funktioniert.
Aber, aber so die Details, also sprich das da, so die letzten...
Huge, huge Graphics Skill.
Ähm...
So die letzten...
Sind zwar keine 10...
Ja, ja, ist ja auch egal.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ähm...
So die letzten 10 Prozent, die haben sie noch nicht hingekriegt.
So ist es mit Linux auf dem Desktop.
Ist ganz genauso.
Das ist auch, das ist auch wo sie X durch Wayland jetzt ablösen wollen.
Oder so.
Man...
Es fällt ihnen dann immer wieder auf.
Oder es ist ja generell so bei, bei Projekten, dass es einem immer wieder auffällt.
So nach dem Motto, ah Mist.
Jetzt am Ende muss man auch die Sachen, die man angefangen hat, richtig fertig machen,
dass es halt komplett taugt.
Und genau das Problem ist, was halt auch mit Linux auf dem Desktop haben.
Äh, ja, grafische Ausgabe gut, funktioniert, alles, alles super.
Ah, Multi-Monitor-Ausgabe.
Hm...
Da, da haben wir schon ein bisschen Probleme mit.
Ja.
Es ist nicht so, als hätte Mac und, und Windows auch irgendwelche Probleme.
Was das angeht.
Ähm, aber Linux hat halt so ein paar Punkte, die immer, wo du früher oder, früher oder
später, dann erstmal vor allem als Neueinsteiger auf dem Desktop vor so einer Wand stehst,
wo du nicht genau weißt, was du machen sollst.
Und entweder es geht gar nicht, kann ja auch sein, dass irgendwas ist, was einfach nicht
funktioniert.
Oder es muss halt gefrickelt werden.
Deswegen sag ich ja, wenn man, wenn man auf Linux umsteigen will, darf man sich nicht
einreden.
Es wäre ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein,
nicht würdel shot dazu.
Ja.
Los los, es ist Windows.
Ne, es, es, es was ganz was anderes.
Was kann der neue Edge eigentlich?
Wir gucken uns gleich ein Microsoft Edge Review an.
Der ist auf Chrome basiert, der.
Ja, auf, auf Plink heißt der, oder?
Plink.
Gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns den an.
Wir gucken jetzt mal ein neues Chrome, äh nicht Chrisр, natürlich Edge, Review an.
Diesen komischen Channel, ne.
Den kriegen wir jetzt die ganze Zeit empfohlen, weil wir mal ein Video geguckt haben.
Ah, ähm.
Der Hypetream, Hype Stream, der hat Erfolg.
Huge.
Das Gamma-Strain lebt
Zeig deinen Support im Chat
Okay, ich soll mich jetzt selbst supporten im Chat
Wuppes
Aber hier, Hauptsache es geht nach oben
Weißt du, zufällig
Was?
Wie Twitch Leute mehr bekommen
Über Prime oder ganz anders
Du bekommst genau das gleiche
Vom Prime-Sub
Wie vom normalen Sub, das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied
Aber
Seit es Prime gibt, sind die Sub-Zahlen
Mit Sicherheit deutlich hochgegangen
That's why I season my cutting board
Not my steak
Ah yes, excellent
Ah yes, exquisite
So, also gucken wir uns mal hier
Edge an
Gucken was hier WindowsArea.de
Zum neuen Edge sagt
Ich bin's auch noch von WindowsArea.de
Und der neue Microsoft Edge Browser
Ist endlich da
Leute, Leute, ganz ehrlich
Ich konnte mich kaum halten
Ich hab schon wirklich jeden Morgen
Wo ich aufgewacht bin
Bin ich auf heiße gegangen
Ist der Edge da?
Ist der neue Edge da?
Und jetzt ist er da
Ich konnte mich echt nicht halten
So, gucken wir mal
Alter, was ist das hier?
Warum geht der Fullscreen nicht?
Wir verarschen den jetzt
Ah, da ist ein neues Fenster auf
Ah, Fullscreen
Und der neue Microsoft Edge Browser
Ist endlich da
Was daran neu ist
Wieso es plötzlich ein neues Logo gibt
Und wie gut der Browser überhaupt ist
Es gibt ein neues Logo
Wisst ihr wie das aussieht?
Wie ein Wartekursor
Also wenn das das neue Edge Logo ist
Was wahrscheinlich wirklich stimmt
Das sieht aus wie ein Wartelogo
Hat er schon geupdatet?
Ne
Welcome to Edge
Oh, ich hatte den noch nie offen
Das ist aber noch der alte Edge
Windows Update
Oh, ne, ne, ne, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Das machen wir jetzt nicht
Verraten wir euch in diesem objektiven Review
Wo wir Stärken und Schwächen aufzeigen
Laut genug
Und ihn am Ende auch noch mit anderen alternativen Browsern vergleichen
Ich, dafür bin ich ein bisschen leise, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an
WTF, warum bin ich so leise?
Warum, das, das, das muss ich erstmal
Das, warum ändert Windows immer die Sound Settings?
Ja, Audio passt, aber es ist jedes Mal anders
Ich weiß nicht, was Windows macht
Also ich meine, an meinem Setup ändert sich ja nichts
Das ist ja alles genauso angeschlossen wie vorher
Aber mal hänge ich da im Durchschnitt
Mal hänge ich da im Durchschnitt
Und ich, ich könnte wetten
Das liegt daran, weil ich die Audio Settings
Also weil ich Audioaufnahme
Zum Beispiel auf beiden Windows Accounts verwende
Und der der Meinung ist
Irgendwie dies verstellen zu müssen
Zwischen beiden Accounts
Irgendwie so
AI supported Audio Settings
Wahrscheinlich
Der neue Microsoft Edge hat ein neues Logo
Sieht plötzlich anders aus
Huge Edge
Und der ist plötzlich irgendwie besser
Also wesentlich besser
Und da könnt ihr euch eigentlich bei Google bedanken
Denn der neue Microsoft Edge
Hat ein neues Logo
Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich da bei Google bedanken muss
Letztendlich hat Microsoft den Kram über Bord geschmissen
Und hat das verwendet
Was 50 andere Browser auch schon verwenden
Also hat er denselben Kern
Wie Google Chrome
Das bedeutet, er ist endlich schnell
Seitenladen perfekt
Und es gibt keine lästigen Hänger
Danke Google
Ok, Google hat nichts davon
Denn Microsoft schmeißt all deren Tracking raus
Und das darf man einfach so machen
Weil Chromium ist Open Source
Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr euch auch
Einen eigenen Browser machen
Hm, der neue Albert Browser
Mit Pornhub immer als Startseite
Und unendlichen Toolbars
Die stöhnen Geräusche machen
Hm
Also eigentlich eh wie der Internet Explorer
Viel Swire, man
Aber ja, dasselbe machen auch Opera, Vivaldi, Brave, Blisk
Der Epic Browser
Ja, das waren alle, so sieht's aus
Nur Firefox und Safari drehen noch ihr eigenes Ding
Aber Microsoft macht Schluss damit
Der neue Edge ist erst am 15. Januar 2020 fertiggekommen
Also ist er praktisch noch druckfrisch
Im Laufe der nächsten Zeit will Microsoft den Chromium Edge als Standardbrowser in den
Also für Screen Capture war nix mehr, war nix mehr
Oder ist es, ist es einfach stylischer, das vom Notebook abzufüllen?
Windows 10 in sich dann
Aber wie kriegt man den neuen Edge jetzt?
Ganz einfach, man lädt ihn, genauso wie Chrome, nur eben von Microsofts Webseite
Es ist so fail
Aber man
Es ist so fail, Windows
Warum muss man so ne Kacke übers Internet runterladen?
Warum?
Warum gibt es immer noch keinen ordentlichen Package Manager?
Warum muss man nicht Microsoft verwendet?
Jedes Mal, wenn ich sowas sehe, äh, rege ich mich da drüber auf
Natürlich nicht Microsoft, wenn man euch damit nicht wenigstens ein kleines bisschen an die
Pelle rücken würde
In nächster Zeit wird er nämlich auch per Windows Update für alle Windows 10 Nutzer
kommen
Ja, das ist mir wurscht, kannste ruhig machen
Den alten Edge ersetzen
Also, ersetzen jetzt nicht so im klassischen Sinn, dass man eine Sache wegnimmt und die
andere Sache stattdessen dazu gibt
Konsequent, wie man bei Microsoft bekanntermaßen ist, bleibt der alte Edge fürs erste oder
auch länger in Windows 10 integriert
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein IE
Wir haben jetzt ein IE
Wir haben einen Edge IE Compatibility Mode
Wir haben einen Edge und wir haben einen neuen Edge
Huge Microsoft, big brain time
Ehe keiner von euch nutzt, greifen auf den alten Edge zurück und all diese Apps würden
jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren, wenn man ihn einfach streicht
Ja, das ist richtig
Also bleibt auch der alte in Windows 10 erhalten
Damit kommt Windows 10 in Zukunft mit drei Browsern von Microsoft an Bord und die EU verkauft
Microsoft auch noch, weil es keine Auswahl gibt
Internet Explorer, Microsoft Edge und nochmal Microsoft Edge
Wer braucht da schon mehr Auswahl?
Oh, und wie war das denn mit dem Benutzererlebnis so, wenn man den neuen Edge über den Browser
installiert?
Nun, am ersten Tag war es problematisch
Da hatten nämlich viele Nutzer aus irgendeinem Grund einen Installer bekommen, in einer Sprache,
die sie gar nicht sprechen
Bei meinem Kollegen Armin war der Installer einfach mal in Spanisch und ich habe gehört,
bei Semper Video war er sogar Deutsch
Zum Glück hat ihm jemand gesagt
Zum Glück hat ihm jemand die Installation vorher Schritt für Schritt in einem Video erklärt
Aber ansonsten, bei mir lief eigentlich alles ziemlich reibungslos ab
Hat man den Browser installiert, kann man die Synchronisation mit dem Microsoft Account einschalten
und entscheiden, ob man personalisierte Werbung bekommen will
Der Schalter ist hier standardmäßig
Ja, unbedingt, ich möchte unbedingt Werbung bekommen, Microsoft, dafür brauche ich einen neuen Browser
Ich hoffe nein, dass das ein ganz nettes Detail ist
Dann kann es auch schon losgehen mit dem Surfen
Unbedingt
Denn beim neuen Edge werden die gespeicherten Passwörter und Favoriten synchronisiert und das außerordentlich zugeschaltet wird
Zuverlässig
Bevor ich aber zu den einzigartigen
Das will ich aber gar nicht
Also ich will nicht, dass automatisch Passwörter synchronisiert werden
Das ist für mich ein absoluter Grund, das nicht zu verwenden
Wenn ich zu den Features von Edge komme, möchte ich noch einige wenige Worte zum Surferlebnis an sich verlieren
Es ist nämlich einfach perfekt
Der Browser fühlt sich schlank und schnell an, was auch daran liegt, dass Microsoft ordentlich an der Effizienz geschraubt hat
Die Chromebasis macht aber besonders bei der Seitendarstellung eine große Herausforderung
Wo der alte Edge immer wieder Probleme mit YouTube und Google Docs hatte, hm woran das wohl liegt, zeigt der neue Edge alle Seiten so an, wie sie es auf Chrome macht
Und aus Benutzersicht ist das richtig klasse
Aber dazu gibt es auch eine weitere, nähere Sichtweise
Aber ich meine, genau, es ist halt Chrome
Zu der ich am Ende noch komme
Mehr gibt es dazu auch nicht zu sagen
Dass Edge aber nicht gleich Chrome ist, das wird besonders bei den Einstellungen klar
Das Menü ist schon etwas übersichtlicher, aber die Einstellungen von Edge gefallen mir persönlich deutlich besser
Als die von Chrome
Und während die Option Datenschutz bei Google gar nicht existiert, ist sie bei Microsoft Edge ganz prominent, fast ganz oben
Standardmäßig nicht
Und vorher kriegen wir erzählt, es werden automatisch alle Passwörter gesynct
Perfekt
Der neue Microsoft Edge einen Trackingschutz implementiert, den Microsoft zusätzlich in den eigenen Browser einbaut
Nutzer finden hier direkt drei Optionen und Edge blockiert von Haus aus alle Cookies von Drittanmetern
Das bedeutet, wenn ihr Facebook nicht benutzt, seid ihr mit Edge selbst verantwortlich
Seid ihr mit Edge sicher vor Facebook-Tracking
Dasselbe gilt für Google, Twitter, Amazon und alle anderen Datenkranken da draußen
Das Datenschutzverhalten in Edge ist ziemlich umfassend
Erlaubt euch das vollständige Deaktivieren von Telemetriedaten
Was erfreulicherweise direkt aus den Einstellungen von Windows 10 übernommen wird
Und hat personalisierte Werbung von Haus aus deaktiviert
Microsoft hat Google aus seinem Chromium-Derivat rausgeschmissen
Und daher ist Bing auch die Standardsuchmaschine in Edge
Das wundert mich nicht
Was man allerdings problemlos ändern kann
Und hat erfreulicherweise auch DuckDuckGo als Alternative angeboten
Für Erweiterungen hat Microsoft einen eigenen Store
Aber der Download aus dem Chrome-Webstore für Erweiterungen ist problemlos möglich
Also geht ihr einfach in den Chrome-Webstore, klickt oben auf diesen Knopf und installiert was ihr haben wollt
Alle Erweiterungen sind hier enthalten
Wie heißt das?
Pling?
Moment
Wie heißt das Kram jetzt?
Pling
Also kann man mit Pling auf Bing suchen dann?
Was für Benahmung
Eine schnelle Seitendarstellung
Synchronisierung mit dem Microsoft-Account
So wie mit dem mobilen Edge-Browser für Android und iPhone
Mehr Datenschutz
Und ein meiner Meinung nach hübscheres Design
So kann man aktuell den Edge-Browser zusammenarbeiten
Erstmal huge Dragpad Skills zeigen
In naher Zukunft wird es noch ein richtig praktisches Feature geben
Das es leider oder besser gesagt typisch Microsoft nicht in den finalen Release geschafft hat
Das sind nämlich die Sammlungen, welche ein echt praktisches Feature sind, das aber noch nicht drin ist
Warum 41 00 was ich mit vesAM zurechtkommen möchte?
Tja, das ist Microsoft.
Man ist einfach nicht fertig geworden.
Die Sammlungen sind aber mein absolutes Lieblings-
Ja, es syncht sich wahrscheinlich auch automatisch.
Ganz ehrlich, ein Grund zum Wechseln.
Die Sammlungen sind ein Ort, wo ihr Webseiten, also Links, Bilder und Notizen einfach ablegen könnt.
Stellt euch vor, ihr schreibt eine A-
Dafür habe ich einmal mein Notizprogramm und vor allem meinen Bookmark-Sync in die Nextcloud.
Arbeit für die Schule oder Uni und ihr recherchiert dafür.
Was bei mir immer so aussieht, dass eine Google-Suche und daneben 90 Tabs offen sind.
Alle notwendigen Seiten, alle Bilder und eben einige eigene Notizen könnt ihr direkt im Browser abnehmen.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Die Sammlungen werden auch zwischen euren Geräten ver-
Wenn man so voll auf diese Microsoft-Geschichte steht, ist das wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt.
Und ohne Spaß, ich kann nicht mehr ohne.
Ohne Spaß, Leute.
Ich kenne vor kurzem ähnliche Dienste, aber das ist einfach so viel besser und noch dazu direkt im Browser drin.
Darum ist es auch besonders schade, dass das beste Feature geradezu-
Im Start nicht drin ist.
Kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt und vergleichen wir Edge mit der Konkurrenz.
Ja, neues Testament, denk schon.
Und rein technisch, da gibt es wenige Unterschiede, denn im Kern sind sie ja beide gleich.
Ich glaube, man kann Inhalte speichern, Links speichern und eigene Notizen irgendwie so zusammenheften und dann halt lokal abspeichern.
Liegen einmal bei den Sammlungen, es gibt einige klitzekleine Design-Vorzüge bei Edge und natürlich wäre da noch der Datenschutz.
Und man kann von Microsoft halten, was man will.
Aber?
Edge ist ohne Zweifel beim Datenschutz ein enormer Schritt im Vergleich zu Google Chrome.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, und das verstehe ich natürlich, weiß ich nicht so genau, ob man Microsoft wirklich das Thema Datenschutz so abkauft.
Ja, der Edge hat diesen Trackingschutz integriert.
Er deaktiviert personalisierte Werbung und sammelt keine Telemetriedaten, wenn man das so will.
Es gibt aber Anbieter wie Brave, aber auch-
Sag mal, welche Settings gewinnen denn eigentlich dann?
Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt in Edge sage, ich möchte keine Telemetrie?
Ich möchte Telemetriedaten sammeln, aber in Windows kann ich ja gar nicht ausschalten, dass man Telemetriedaten sammelt.
Ist Windows größer Edge oder Edge größer Windows in dem Fall?
Weil was bringt es mir, wenn ich das in Edge ausschalte, aber Windows trotzdem sammelt?
... Firefox, bei denen das Thema Datenschutz ohne jeden Zweifel auch glaubwürdiger aufgehoben ist.
Firefox, so gut er auch beim Datenschutz sein mag, ist besonders für Laptop-Nutzer aufgrund des veralteten Scrolling-Mechanismus und der wirklich schlechten Effizienz eine ziemlich schlechte Option.
Das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Wer allerdings die Chrome-Potenz im Netz nicht fördern will, für den ist Firefox wohl die beste Option.
Ist das so?
Habe ich keine Ahnung, ob das auf dem Notebook so ineffizient ist.
So ein JavaScript-Benchmark macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied, was du verwendest.
Für einen Browser, das nimmt sich alles nicht großartig was.
Manchmal ist Firefox schneller, manchmal ist Chrome schneller.
Safari ist, glaube ich, immer so ziemlich am Arsch bei fast allen Benchmarks.
Mich würde es wundern, wenn Firefox das irgendwie nennt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da eine auswertere Auswirkung drauf hat.
Microsoft Edge ist ein wirklich guter Browser.
Er ist der beste Browser, den Microsoft je gebaut hat.
Und für die meisten Kunden ist er wohl auch der beste Browser überhaupt.
Er ist genauso schnell wie Chrome, bietet eine Datenschutzausrede, sage ich mal, mit der die meisten von uns ganz ehrlich gut genug leben können.
Und er ist direkt in Windows integriert.
Wer Chrome nun aus dem Netz holt, hat damit nur noch einen Browser mehr, der dasselbe kann und nur schlechter ab-
Ah, yes. Alles klar, Leute.
Also, wir haben alles gelesen, das Privacy-Statement haben wir auch alles gelesen, das ist kein Problem, easy, except download.
Los.
So, auf geht's.
Warum braucht es Admin-Berechtigung?
Das ist ein fucking Browser, der braucht keine Admin-Berechtigung.
Okay.
Das ist Microsoft, der braucht Admin-Berechtigung, ist klar.
Warum braucht ein Browser Admin-Berechtigung?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Ah, yes, Admin-Berechtigung für alles.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Warum?
Weil es geht.
Das ist Microsoft-Logik.
Warum brauche ich einen Browser Admin-Berechtigung?
Oh, da ist er.
Leute.
Edge ist da.
Signing in.
Äh.
Signing in?
Mit was?
Hat er sich jetzt mit irgendeinem Account eingesigned?
Das muss ich jetzt gleich mal angucken.
Okay.
Getting started.
You can customize your tabs.
Info-
Focused.
Seht keinen Unterschied.
Ach, das ist nur die Startseite.
Oder was?
Vollkommen wurscht.
Ähm.
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Install for all users.
Ja, ich wollte es ja gar nicht für all users installieren.
Aber ich hatte keine Auswahl.
Ich hätte keine Auswahl.
Ich hätte es am liebsten nur für meinen User installiert.
Ich will nicht synchen.
Okay.
Profile 1.
Er hat sich nicht eingeloggt.
Wo auch immer.
So.
Chrome.
Also.
Guck mal erst mal.
YouTube.
Also was mir gefällt ist, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Aber bei allen UWP-Apps, das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch zumindest hier oben.
Es wird eine UWP-App sein oder vielleicht schon eine neue WinUI3-Anwendung.
Mal gucken.
Aber was mir bei den ganzen UWP-Apps gefällt tatsächlich ist das Font-Rendering.
Das ist ja auch so eine Microsoft-Geschichte, dass das Font-Rendering überall anders aussieht.
Also die Fonts sehen in Forms anders aus wie in WPF aus und in UWP anders aus und in WinAPI-Geschichten
wahrscheinlich wie in Windows Forms.
Und es ist wir.
Ja.
Verwendest du eine GTK, eine Qt oder sonst was an, dann sieht das Font-Rendering nochmal
ein bisschen anders aus.
Ähm.
Ah.
Bing.
Git.
Geh fort.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Okay.
Also immer muss man sagen, die Seite fühlt sich wirklich sehr responsive und schnell
an.
Aber ich meine, es ist Chrome.
Das fühlt sich da immer so an.
Ich brauche mal ein Video von mir mit hoher Auflösung.
Dann nehmen wir mal das Battlefield-Fazit-Video.
Das funktioniert immer gut.
Ähm.
Dann gucken wir mal, wie viel.
Wir gucken mal, wie viel RAM das Ding braucht.
Gucken wir mal, wie viel RAM das Teil braucht.
Edge.
Ah.
MS.
M.
Ah.
MS Edge.
Okay.
Jetzt verbrauchen.
Viel RAM.
Weil es ist ein Chrome.
Da ist also nichts.
Nichts Neues.
Erstmal gleich 300 MB RAM weg.
Weil Browser heute halt 300 MB RAM brauchen.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Hier ist der Max.
Ähm.
Acception.
Gut.
Das läuft relativ geschwind.
Ähm.
Verwendet das GPU-Beschleunigung.
Müssen wir uns das gleich mal anschauen.
GPU-Beschleunigung.
Äh.
Moment.
Warte mal.
Wo sieht man das nochmal?
Ich glaube, das ist halt einfach nur rumgebackt hier gerade.
Ähm.
Ja.
Verwendet GPU.
Schon mal gut.
Ach.
Hier sieht man es auch.
Genau.
Ähm.
Ja.
Verwendet GPU zum Decoden.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Okay.
Erstmal gucken, ob wir, ob wir.
U-Block.
Origin.
Edge.
Wie, wie kriegt man hier, wie kriegt man hier offiziell Erweiterung.
Erweiterung.
Ja Patrick.
Sieben Monate schon am Start.
Big Brain Sub.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Chrome Extensions funktionieren ja.
Ich weiß.
Aber es gibt doch angeblich einen eigenen, einen eigenen, ähm.
Store.
Wie hier.
Extensions.
Hier.
Search in Store.
Microsoft Store.
Ja da ist er.
Guck hier.
Da.
U-Block.
Ja.
Origin.
Ähm.
Das ist, das ist Fake, oder?
Das ist der Richtige.
Ah, der Typ hat das gepackaged für Edge.
Aber das ist ein anderer Typ.
Ich denke, das erleben wir jetzt lieber aus dem Chrome Store.
Gucken wir, ob das funktioniert.
Da.
Go Hill.
Das ist der Richtige.
Genau.
Und jetzt?
Ach so.
Äh.
You can add extension.
Allow.
Aha.
Das ist eigentlich, das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Add.
Okay.
Good.
Oh ja.
Gut.
Wie gehabt.
Ja.
Ist halt, ist halt ein Chrome im Endeffekt.
Kann man sagen, dass, ähm.
So.
Also man muss sagen, dass es, ähm, das Scrolling fühlt sich halt anders an.
Ja.
Das ist halt dieses, dieses UWP Smooth Scrolling.
Wie man hier sieht.
Guck hier.
Zack.
Ja.
Das hat man beispielsweise, ähm, hier nicht.
Wenn man jetzt hier auf, wir gehen mal auf das gleiche Video.
Das kann man jetzt mögen oder nicht.
Das ist Geschmackssache.
Hallo.
Guck.
Also hier hat man halt so das, das, das klassische Scrolling.
So man, man, man scrollt und es scrollt halt.
Und hier im Edge hat man halt dieses, je nachdem wie schnell ich den, den, den, das Mausrad
bewege, dass er noch nachscrollt.
Das ist Geschmackssache.
Ich muss sagen, mir gefällt dieses Scrolling hier eigentlich besser.
Es fühlt sich irgendwie weicher an.
Vor allem, wenn man schön schnell scrollt, scrollt er halt auch schön schnell weiter.
Ähm, das gefällt mir eigentlich besser.
Bisher war es aber halt so, ähm, es gibt halt keine gescheiten Anwendungen, die das verwenden deswegen.
Ja.
Aber das gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich meine, nachdem der Edge im Prinzip in Chrome ist, kann man damit jetzt auch alles machen.
So.
Ähm, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes zu bieten?
Apps.
Install the site as app.
Nee, warum?
Ach, als PWA.
Ah, das unterstützt PWA.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Downloads.
Na gut, da ist nichts interessantes dabei sein.
Download Edge.
Wir, äh, wir downloaden jetzt Edge mit Edge.
Erstmal, Moment.
Suche.
Die Suche muss ich umstellen.
Settings.
Search.
Ja.
Äh.
Klammer.
Duck, duck, go.
Giet's.
Ah, nee, man muss die speichern.
Speichern.
Automatisch.
Edge.
Download.
Laut vorlesen ist das Beste.
Wie kann man, wie kann man vorlesen?
Ah, hier.
Microsoft Edge.
Free and safe download.
Ah, ja.
Naja, gut.
Haha.
Ähm.
Ich will einfach nur mal über die Downloads angucken.
Wie das funktioniert.
So.
Download Edge.
Accept.
Jawoll.
Thank you.
Ist genau das Gleiche.
Show in Folder.
Geht hier.
Und was haben wir sonst noch?
Downloads.
Hier hat man.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick.
Das ist beim Chrome immer ein bisschen doof.
Ähm.
Wenn man sich im Chrome die Downloads anguckt.
Dann hat man halt hier dieses Ding.
Ähm.
Deswegen finde ich das, das eigentlich ganz gut.
G D I J Z Martin.
6 Monate.
Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Subscriber Prime.
Subscriber.
Na, na, na, na, nice.
Aber die Übersicht finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ähm.
Ich bin ja jemand, der löscht, der löscht seine, seine, seine Download History immer.
Weiß eigentlich nicht warum.
Die paar Kilobyte machen es eigentlich überhaupt nicht fett.
Okay.
Was können wir, was können wir sonst noch angucken?
Ich meine, es ist halt, es ist halt ein Browser.
Was, was, was wollen wir da großartig noch gucken?
Äh.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Da gibt es eigentlich, da gibt es nicht mal viel zu gucken, oder?
Funktioniert, wie, wie, wie funktioniert Fullscreen?
Ah, Fullscreen laggt.
Okay.
Fullscreen laggt.
Huge.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Huge lag.
Fullscreen.
Mal hier.
Bam.
Lagging Fullscreen.
Geht mir schon auf den Keks.
Wir müssen noch gucken.
Äh.
WebGL-Test.
Wir müssen gucken, wie, wie schnell das Aquarium ist.
Das, das alles.
Das Allerwichtigste.
Der Aquarium-Test müssen wir machen.
Okay.
30.000.
Bam.
Fünfwöchig FPS.
Der Aquarium-Test.
Wichtigste.
Canvas hide.
Change.
Oh.
Huge Background.
Massive Background-Image.
Ganz schön voll.
So.
Wo kann man jetzt die Größe vom Tank einstellen?
Will die Größe vom Tank einstellen?
Okay.
Geht.
Geht anscheinend nicht.
Bitrat.
Ja, ich seh's.
Und das, obwohl wir hier schon unterwegs sind mit 5 Mbit.
5 Mbit ist für Desktop eigentlich schon ein bisschen verordnet.
Okay.
Es ist halt ein Browser.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da jetzt noch großartig ausprobieren soll.
Es ist ein Browser.
Und er browsed.
Also, alles gut.
Ähm.
Ha.
Nein.
Geht sofort aus.
Den hab ich schon installiert.
Äh.
Wie sieht's mit Private Browsing aus?
Okay.
Gibt's ein Dark Theme?
Das ist wichtig.
Dunkel.
Wir haben das ja auf Deutsch.
Nee.
Ähm.
Theme.
Hier.
Die können sich nicht so ganz entscheiden, ob man's auf Deutsch oder Englisch hat, oder?
Ach nee.
Doch.
Wir haben's auf Englisch.
Bin ich doof, ey.
Dark.
Ich hab's ja komplett auf Englisch stehen.
Hier.
Theme.
Also, wir stellen das erst mal auf Dark Theme.
Alles gut.
Passt.
Kommt gleich viel angenehmer.
Zumindest, zumindest halt, wenn man in den Settings ist.
Der neue Edge kann 4K bei Netflix und Prime.
Wieso kann das Chrome nicht?
Das kann doch, das können doch wahrscheinlich alle Browser.
Oder auch nicht?
Ich hab 4K, ich hab 4K Netflix noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab übrigens Netflix, äh, jetzt einen Account gemacht für die Witcher-Serie, ne?
Nur dafür.
Und, äh, ich bin jetzt, bin jetzt zur Hälfte durch mit der Serie beim gucken.
Und ich bin immer noch so wirklich nicht, nicht so wirklich begeistert.
So viel verschenktes Potential.
Am besten sind die Szenen, wenn hier Dandelion und Geralt ein bisschen Blödsinn schwätzen.
Und Folge 3 war bisher am besten.
Danach wird's, danach wird's schwächer.
Ach so.
Chrome kann nur 1.800...
Warum?
Wegen DRM.
Aber Netflix kann 4K.
Das ist, das ist mal Logik.
Ähm.
Aber es muss doch irgendeine Möglichkeit geben, unter Windows Netflix in 4K abzuspielen.
Ach so, ja gut.
Wenn man die App verwenden kann, dann ist das ja gut.
So.
Machen wir Edge mal wieder zu.
Wir haben Edge installiert.
Edge Review haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal an.
What happened to Stadia?
Das ist ja wieder, das ist wieder ein schönes Thema für mich.
Da kann ich wieder ein bisschen flamen.
Also Edge hat die Technologie für DRM 4K drin.
Chrome nicht.
Da frage ich mich, was für eine krasse 4K DRM-Technologie man braucht, was 1080p DRM nicht hat.
Stadia dead.
Stadia, ich hab euch ja das letztens mal gezeigt.
Ich hab euch das ja letztens mal gezeigt, die Spielerverteilung.
Stadia zu Rest.
Ähm.
Übrigens hier, mein neues, mein neues Lieblings-T-Shirt.
Hab ich, hab ich, solange es sauber ist, hab ich es direkt an.
Beste.
Äh.
Hier.
Stadia.
Also das da oben ist Stadia.
Das da.
Hier.
Ist Stadia.
Destiny Spieler.
Ähm.
Und das hier ist PC.
Das ist Playstation.
Das ist Xbox.
Also.
Für eines der Vorzeigetitel auf Stadia ist das natürlich ein HUGE Erfolg.
Ja.
Und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, was Google gesagt hat.
Ähm.
Was Google zu Stadia gesagt hat.
Und zwar.
Es wäre für sie fast schon.
Wie haben sie es ausgedrückt?
Eine.
Ein.
Wie kann man Marketing.
Wie kann man Marketing-technisch schön Misserfolg ausdrücken?
Eine Enttäuschung haben sie gesagt.
Genau.
Es wäre fast schon eine Enttäuschung, wenn sie nur so viele Spieler wie die Playstation
erreichen würden.
Nur so viele.
Das wäre schon fast eine Enttäuschung.
Ja.
Also.
Man sieht.
Dass.
Äh.
Das Hirn.
Der Google Manager.
Und die Realität.
Ein wenig auseinander gehen.
Haben sie nicht was von negativen Input-Leckungen?
Ja.
Haben sie auch.
Aber das fand ich halt die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit.
Haben sie auch.
Aber das fand ich halt die geilste Aussage.
So nach dem Motto.
Sie haben die Chance hier viel, viel mehr Leute zu erreichen.
Weil.
Man braucht ja nur den Chrome.
Und man braucht ja nur hier.
Und braucht ja nur das.
Und das wäre für sie schon fast eine Enttäuschung.
Wenn man nur so viele Spieler wie die Playstation hätte.
Und da habe ich mir damals schon gedacht.
Aber.
Gut.
Ihr wisst ja wie das ist.
Wenn man keine Ahnung hat.
Und nur.
Ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen labern kann.
Dann muss man sich halt selbst in das richtige.
Wie sagt man so schön.
Mindset versetzen.
Ob das mit der Realität.
Aber.
Was zu tun hat.
Oder nicht.
Ist dann erst mal zweitrangig.
Deswegen.
Sag ich ja auch hier.
Da.
Wir können.
Wir können schon mal.
Wir können schon mal einen Platz.
Wir können hier schon mal einen Platz.
Für.
Für Stadia frei halten.
So.
Also.
Gucken wir uns mal.
What happened to Stadia.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob wir schon geguckt haben.
Wenn wir schon geguckt haben.
Machen wir aus.
So.
It's now 2020.
Google Stadia launched during the 2019.
Es ist nicht 2020.
Es ist 2K20.
Wenn schon.
X.
Dich.
sellend.
Datum Schreibweise.
Was sagt der auch.
Ganz davon abgesehen.
Leute.
Ich habe es euch am Anfang gesagt.
Ich bestelle ja fast.
Also.
Ich bestelle ja fast alles und das heißt schon was wenn ich was abbestelle.
Und ich hab Stadia die Founders Edition abbestellt.
Weil.
Also ich hab es schon ein paar mal erzählt.
Aber das muss ich noch mal sagen.
Wollen wir gerade ein Stadia Video gucken.
Weil.
Sie es nicht geschafft haben.
Eine Founders Edition die ich drei Monate vorher preordert habe zu.
So.
so zu verschicken, dass sie zu Release ankommt.
Und nicht nur, dass die irgendwie etwas später ankommt.
Die wollten mir das, glaube ich, drei Wochen nach Release zuschicken.
Da habe ich mir gesagt, Google, ihr könnt mich mal canceln.
Also Felix Spitzer, was die im Vorfeld gelabert haben, deckt sich jetzt damit aber gar nicht.
Ich meine, dass das technologisch eine Herausforderung ist, das sind wir uns alle einig.
Aber dass es nur Technologieentwicklung für die ist, ich weiß nicht.
Also wenn man das im Vorfeld anpreist als Alternative zu anderen Plattformen,
dann muss man sich auch daran messen lassen, ob man wirklich eine Alternative zu anderen Plattformen ist.
Und wenn man sich die Spielzahlen anguckt, sehen die meisten Leute das aktuell noch nicht so.
Ich glaube übrigens...
Auch wenn ich gerade gesagt habe, das wird auf dem Google-Friedhof landen,
glaube ich, ich glaube es nicht wirklich, dass es auf dem Google-Friedhof landen wird,
weil im ganzen Gaming, dieser ganze Gaming-Sektor, da steckt so viel Kohle drin.
Google wird das auch eine Weile weiter betreiben, auch wenn sie da nicht viel Geld mit verdienen.
Garantiert. Das wird nicht auf dem Friedhof landen in den nächsten paar Monaten.
Oder auch nicht in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren. Denke ich mal.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Angeblich kommen bald über 100 Spiele. Ja, Half-Life 3 kommt auch bald.
In Deutschland wird Stadia nie richtig funktionieren.
Zumindest nicht die nächsten 5 bis 10 Jahre. Nie.
Was sagen die? Mindestens 30 Mbit, besser 50 Mbit für einen ordentlichen High-Quality, hoher Auflösungs-Stream?
Wer hat denn das?
Das hat, das hat, das hat, wenn man, wenn man sehr, sehr großzügig sind,
haben das vielleicht 50% der Leute in Deutschland, wenn man großzügig sind.
Eher, eher wahrscheinlich 30% oder so.
Es funktioniert wirklich gut und es sieht gut aus.
Es könnte sogar für bestimmte Leute nützlich sein.
Vielleicht für Leute, die nicht so viele Spiele spielen, nur ein solches paar.
Vielleicht wollen sie Spiele spielen, während sie reisen.
Vielleicht wollen Leute Spiele spielen in einem Hotelraum oder so.
Und nicht mit einem Laptop oder einem Switch. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber Google will 10 Dollar pro Monat für Stadia Pro.
Als eine Abonnierung.
Ja.
Das gibt dir Zugang.
Das finde ich übrigens auch total beknackt, ja.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, wenn du dir einen Xbox Game Pass kaufst, da kriegst du ja wenigstens noch was dabei.
Ich meine, allein schon, allein schon das hier.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn für ein bescheuerter Pro?
Das ist so eine, das ist ja so eine Liste nach dem Motto, was man alles dafür kriegt, ja.
Auflösung bis zu 4K.
Framerate bis zu 60 FPS.
Sound bis zu 5.1.
Und dann ein weiterer Punkt.
Buy Games.
Nein.
Wirklich.
Whenever you want.
Ansonsten spawnt ein Google-Typ hinter mir und sagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, jetzt darfst du keine Spiele kaufen.
Das ist total, also...
Das ist absolut unverschämter Preis für nichts im Endeffekt.
Das ist auch was, was ich an dem Ganzen...
Leute, ich hab, ich hab...
Ich hab nicht ein automatisches Abo gemacht, dadurch, dass ich die Founders Edition bestellt habe, oder?
Nicht, dass die mir jetzt jeden Monat...
Nicht, dass die mir jetzt jeden Monat 9,99 Euro abbuchen.
Das muss ich mal nachgucken.
Ich trau das, ich trau das denen alles zu.
Ich muss mir das mal aufschreiben, ich muss da nachher nachgucken, ja.
Konto leer.
Ey, dann bezahl...
Ich, ich, ich guck mir das ja nie so genau an.
Dann bezahl ich die nächsten 10 Jahre Google Stadia, obwohl ich's nicht benutze.
Hab ich ein Stadia-Abo?
Muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Guck doch im Stream nach, ja.
Huge excellent forklag.
Ja, abbestellt.
Ja, abgestellt.
Huge Auflösung.
Ja, es ist halt, ich find's, ich find's an sich, also, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wofür Leute bei Nintendo Online Geld bezahlen, aber das ist zumindest nicht so viel, ja, es ist zwar immer noch zu viel für das, was man kriegt, aber das, 10 Euro im Monat im Endeffekt, einfach nur, dass man es benutzen darf.
Wenn ich mir überlege, ich kann mir einen Xbox-PC-Gamepass kaufen, für was? 4,99 Euro im Monat? Ähm, oder ne, was kostet der? Xbox-PC-Gamepass, äh, kostet, ja, Preis, Preis, Alter, sag mir einfach, was das kostet.
Nintendo ist nett, wenn man NES und SNES spielt, dafür kann ich einen Emulator benutzen.
Ich seh's nicht ein, mir zum 25. Mal.
Man kann sagen, ja, ist schön, ähm, Entwickler unterstützen und sowas, aber ich kauf mir jetzt nicht beispielsweise, ähm, Super Mario World zum 5. Mal. Wirklich nett.
Ja, also, ich kann mir quasi für die Hälfte einen Microsoft-Gamepass holen, wo richtig viele hochqualitative Spiele mit dabei sind.
Bekommst kostenlos, bekomm ich nicht kostenlos, ich muss einen Nintendo-Gamepass abschließen, oder wie das heißt, dass ich's kriege, das ist nicht kostenlos.
Nee, nee, nee, 12 Euro kostet nicht.
Der Gamepass, 12 Euro kostet der, der All-Inclusive-Xbox-PC-Gedöns-Gamepass.
Es gibt nen, es gibt nen, es gibt nen extra Windows-Games- oder PC-Xbox-PC-Gamepass.
Der hat richtig viele gute Spiele drin, für 3,99 oder 4,99 im Monat.
Ey, sogar Origin X ist besser.
Ich mein, und dann muss ich mir die Spiele auf der Sätschau gekauft haben.
Ein Vierteljährlich, ja.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Exactly what you're getting.
And first impressions are very important.
And if you're confused, that's a bad thing.
Das Problem ist, dass man bei Google an...
dass man bei Google-Produkten in letzter Zeit immer confused ist.
Guckt euch auch nochmal nur die User-Settings an.
Du hast, also wenn du...
wenn du auf YouTube aktiv bist, du hast...
20...
20 Orte, wo du Settings vornehmen kannst, die irgendwie Auswirkungen auf dein Google-Account, Google-Konto oder sonst was haben.
Es blickt kein Mensch mehr durch.
Das war eine Cringe-Werbung.
Ich meine, wer bei Google ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, dass dieses Konstrukt hier auch nur ansatzweise eine Switch-Konkurrenz machen könnte.
Das sieht aus wie ein Hobby-Projekt von jemandem, der einen 3D-Drucker hat.
Aber das meinen die ernst.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das könnte ich bei mir aus dem 3D-Drucker ausdrucken.
Dann geht das Ganze noch nicht mal über Plus.
Bluetooth-Wireless. Warum musst du ein Kabel anstecken?
Das sieht aus wie ein Kickstarter-Projekt, was während der Entwicklung des Kickstarters immer weiter downgradet wird.
Und am Ende kommt sowas raus.
Potato Churchman. Zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Prime.
Samus.
Samus-Crimer.
Performance was one thing.
It's worth pointing out that plenty of other reviewers had a much better experience than us, more smooth.
But it was all the other...
Smooth?
...other technical stuff that saw some scrutiny and may have alienated more potential buyers.
A lot of outlets like Digital Foundry and stuff confirmed that most of the Stadia games that boasted 4K in big bold letters weren't actually made of 4K output at all.
Destiny 2 is rendered at 1080p and upscaled to 4K to look a little better.
Das ist halt auch der Witz, ne?
Sie erzählen dir was von 4K-Resolution und die Spiele laufen halt alle nicht in 4K-Resolution.
Redemption 2, despite having the infinite computing power of the cloud, couldn't hold a candle to the...
...the same actual version running on an actual PC.
Das sieht halt auch besser auf der Xbox aus.
Google's response seems to have put the responsibility on the developers themselves to make their game take advantage of Stadia's features, like 4K.
Okay, sure.
They are really the ones...
Äh, Dandy, natürlich wechseln.
Es sei denn, du willst dir irgendwie Blödsinn einfangen.
Windows 7 is dead.
Keine Chance, du musst upgraden.
Du kannst, guck mal, du kannst doch sogar deine alte Lizenz behalten.
Du musst doch gar nichts machen.
Du musst einfach nur upgraden.
In dem Fall würde ich tatsächlich sogar neu installieren.
Anstatt es zu upgraden.
Ähm, weiß gar nicht, ob man ordentlich upgraden kann.
Ähm, einfach die wichtigen Sachen speichern auf einer externen Platte.
Und, äh, truff, truff damit.
Du kannst ja upgraden, falls das funktioniert.
Aber du musst wechseln, was anderes bleibt dir nicht übrig.
Wechseln auf Linux, das kann man so pauschal auch nicht empfehlen.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man, wenn man ein Gamer ist.
Ja, dann, dann ab, kannst ja upgraden.
Ich hab's noch nie upgraden von 7 auf 10.
Ich hab immer nur neu installiert von 7 auf 10.
Ich hab noch nie gedownloadet, so dass es Sinn macht.
Aber trotzdem, es ist einfach nur...
Ja, ja, das kostet nichts.
Also du brauchst keine Windows 10 Lizenz zu kaufen.
Du kannst immer noch upgraden mit deinem, oder du kannst dein Windows 7 Key verwenden.
...Damper on the launch.
Because the potential was there for some people who maybe didn't have the money to run out and buy the newest console that supports 4K.
To still get a lot of that exciting action through this streaming service.
You know, I don't know.
But the biggest problem, you know, is that it should have been early access.
It was only playable...
Da hat er recht.
...on a select few types of phones and tablets.
Es ist einfach noch nicht fertig.
Da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Vor allem, warum geht sowas nur auf Pixel-Phones?
Es gibt doch überhaupt keinen Grund, warum das nicht beispielsweise auf einem aktuellen iPhone funktionieren soll,
oder auf einem x-beliebigen anderen Android-Tablet.
Es ist, wie gesagt, es ist Video-Streaming.
Du musst eigentlich nichts können.
Es muss...
Es muss auch nicht mit dem offiziellen Controller gemacht werden.
Wozu?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Und ja, das kann sein.
Es kann sein.
Es ist möglich, dass das jetzt auch auf Samsung-Handys läuft.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber allein schon, dass man sich das fragen muss, sieht man, dass der Staat verkackt ist.
Allein schon, dass als jemand, der das verwenden möchte, nicht direkt weiß, was er tun muss, ist Fail.
Es ist ziemlich schwer, nur eine Bewertung zu bekommen, wie viele Leute tatsächlich auf Stadia spielen.
Die Antwort war nicht super laut.
Weißt du, der Stat-Tracking-Bot Charlemagne hat gesagt, dass er am Ende November 9.900...
Das da, das, was er gerade erwähnt hat, ist das, was ich euch eben gerade gezeigt habe auf die Grafik von mir auf Twitter.
Ist, habe ich von der gleichen Seite, die er auch erwähnt, diesen Charles LeMaine, was auch immer,
ähm, Bot, ähm, das ist jetzt die gleiche Datenquelle.
Ja, also das hier und das, was er gerade im Video erzählt.
Das war on Release, mittlerweile sind es noch weniger.
Ja, ich meine, es sind, es sind 10.000 Stadia-Spieler zu 1.000.000 auf der anderen Plattform.
Und dann sagen die Google-Leuten auch, es wäre für sie eine Enttäuschung, wenn sie nur so viel erreichen würden wie auf der Playstation.
Das ist halt lächerlich, ja.
1,3 sogar.
Gut, es war im Dezember.
Und, und, und soweit ich weiß, es ist ja auch nicht in keinster Weise Crossplay, oder?
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Also sprich, Stadia-Leute spielen nur mit Stadia-Leuten.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ein, äh, ein Destiny 2 mit nur 10.000 aktiven Spielern,
über das Komplett, über den kompletten Content gestreckt, dass im Endeffekt niemand, ähm, das,
den, den höheren Content je spielen wird auf Stadia.
Weil es keine Leute gibt.
All who are playing it, that's it.
Uh, hell, it might be just people logging in at work or at school, just to redeem some rewards or something.
I don't know, PC Games N reported that on November 20th, Stadia had 44 players in Crucible, 13 players in PvP.
44 Spieler in PvP.
Ja, hoi, joi, joi, joi, joi, da geht's aber.
52 Players in Raids.
Das ist, like, 100 people playing all the non-PVE-Modes, and that's kind of crazy.
Here in the office, some of our Destiny-Guys, the fans, uh, definitely had trouble finding matches.
Now, you might say, well, everyone hates Destiny, so that's why no one's playing it.
Which, that, that, that's fine if you think you do you, but the numbers don't lie on the actual game.
And it's at least somewhat of a gauge on the response of Stadia, considering it had everything going for it,
including being free and having cross-account progression.
And still, this is where we're at.
Ja, Battlefield 3 spielen mehr Leute aktiv.
The potential for all this is there.
I still say, I stand by it, the tech is exciting.
And the future possibilities down the line.
Muss ich das mal überlegen, es spielen mehr Leute Battlefield 3 als Destiny auf, auf, auf Stadia.
Guckt, guckt.
Also insgesamt.
BF3-Stats.
Äh, nicht AP, B, wo?
Oh, nee.
Was?
Warum?
Keine, keine Battlefield-Stats mehr.
Dabei hat der Typ...
...einen echt ganz kompetenten Eindruck gemacht.
Den hab ich zufällig getroffen auf diesem Battlefield-1-Event da, der diese Seiten macht.
Der hat einen ganz guten, der hat eigentlich einen recht kompetenten Eindruck gemacht, als weiß er, was er treibt.
Aber, gut, was.
Leider keinen Bock mehr.
War das nicht in der Links- oder Nachfolge-Seite, echt?
Wo?
Nee, nee.
Das ist, äh, das kommt so auf der gleichen raus.
Das ist RIP.
Warum, warum?
Warum wird denn das eigentlich runtergefahren?
Okay, er hat keine Zeit mehr.
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Kann ich verstehen.
Leuchtet ein.
Maybe you're watching like a how-to-guide-video, and then you click a link, and suddenly you're playing the game.
Ich muss grad mal gucken, dass du das...
Ich hab vergessen, wo er gerade war beim Erzählen.
For all this is there.
I still say, I stand by it, the tech is exciting.
Das stimmt.
And the future possibilities down the line are definitely cool.
You know, watching a YouTube video, or your favorite creator, or maybe you're watching, like, a how-to-guide-video, and then you click a link, and suddenly you're playing the game right there, at that point, on your computer, that's insane.
Das ist cool, das haben sie, glaube ich, sogar auf der, auf der Präsentation gezeigt, aber das geht nicht.
I'm excited for the free version that'll come out in 2020, like they said, because everyone has a Google account.
So, if they do it right, you know, if they do kind of nail this stuff, it could be a win-win.
Ich mach mir echt Gedanken, ob ich nicht ein Stadia-Abo hab durch das Order in der Founders Edition.
Und ich es nicht gesehen habe.
Und ich jetzt schon drei Monate Stadia-Gebühren bezahle.
Let's Player.
Ja, so sieht's denn echt aus, wenn man Stadia zusammenspielt, genau.
Haben das Ding überhaupt mehr als einen Controller?
Ja, es waren drei Monate inbegriffen.
Aber nicht, dass ich danach bezahlen muss.
They've been putting out games consistently every month, and they just need to keep it up and evolve into exactly what people might want.
It seems like they don't know it yet.
Uh, they have a lot to work on, you know, improving the tech, of course, but, uh, bring more feature parity,
more supported devices, and of course, some of those cool features that they talk about in general, that will all only benefit it.
But the biggest battle still, and this is the hardest one, and I'm not even convinced, the battle is convincing people.
A lot of people still have very bad Internet all over the world.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe letztens den
Ted-Talk von dem Typ geguckt,
wo er erzählt hat, was er so getrieben hat
und wie das zu den Fotos gekommen ist.
Ich
sage zwar immer so, das landet auf dem Friedhof
von Google, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass sie es wirklich einstellen.
Dafür ist einfach,
dafür ist das auch alles zu groß,
dieses ganze Gaming-Segment
und Google hat
in diesem Bereich nichts.
Ich meine, die haben YouTube für alles
halt an Videos, aber nichts
was so Steam-mäßig wäre.
Und halt vielleicht
auch die ein oder anderen eigenen Games,
die sie mal machen wollen. Ich meine, Amazon macht
jetzt ein MMO, was demnächst in die Beta geht.
Ja, genau.
Denke ich auch.
Ist das Amazon-MMO
promising? Geiler Satz.
Ähm.
Man sieht davon nicht so viel.
Was ich cool finde, ist, dass es
recht PvP-fokussiert sein soll.
Also ich probiere es auf jeden Fall aus. Vielleicht kriege ich
den Friseur auch dazu überredet.
Ansonsten ist es da erstaunlich
still drum. Ich weiß nicht.
Schwer einzuschätzen, man sieht so wenig von.
Wer ist das?
Wer ist Jade Raymond?
Und ich weiß, dass die Hardcore-Familie
es definitiv nicht hat.
Und die Casual-Familie ist es immer noch viel zu überzeugen,
was es wirklich ist.
Also es ist einer der zwei Wege, wirklich.
Es geht entweder weiter und weiter und wird besser
und findet einen Fußabdruck mit einer respektablen Kundenbasis,
wie es sich weiterbildet, oder
es geht weiter und weiter und wird besser
und dann kann es immer noch
ausfallen. Ich denke, es hätte einen viel breiteren Zukunft,
wenn es nicht andere Services und große
Firmen da wären, die etwas ähnliche Dinge
in verschiedenen Wegen machen würden.
Stadia hat viel Kompetenz.
PC-Gamer haben verschiedene Wege,
wie sie ihre Bibliothek streamen können,
für verschiedene Geräte zu spielen.
Microsofts X-Cloud-Projekt ist immer noch früh,
aber die ersten Impressionen davon sind,
dass sie als Game-Service ziemlich solid sind.
Und zumindest kannst du deine aktuelle Bibliothek
in einem Ökosystem anbieten, in dem du schon Geld
verwendet hast und das Game Pass-Stuff.
Und dann ist Playstation auch auf dem Weg.
Und sie sind alle, vermutlich,
mehr für die nächste Generation.
Ob es jetzt einfach
Streaming-Game sind oder sie für später
benutzt werden, der Wettbewerbs-Deck ist es,
dass es wirklich zusammenhängt.
Und eine Menge dieser Wettbewerbs-Deck
sieht zumindest etwas besser aus als diese Sachen,
ob du sie willst oder nicht.
Das ist also, wo wir sind.
Das ist mehr ein Konversationsvideo.
Wir freuen uns darauf, die Kommentare zu sehen.
Bevor du kommentierst, fragst du dich,
was Google tun würde, um dir Stadia zu machen.
Wenn du das perfekte Internet hättest
und du wolltest, um Stadia zu streamen,
was würde Stadia bedeuten?
Willst du einen Marktplatz?
Willst du einen Laden?
Oder schau dir das an. Wie könnte Stadia
funktionieren?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das fragen sich die Leute bei Google auch gerade.
Wie können wir die Leute davon überzeugen?
Wenn es ja so funktionieren würde.
Moment, Leute.
Warum genau sollte ich mich
in ein Café,
oder was das immer sieht,
eher aus wie ein Badezimmer.
Warum sollte ich mich in ein Badezimmer
mit Tischen und Stühlen setzen,
mit meinem Notebook und dort Stadia spielen?
Hipster-Café.
Das sieht wirklich so aus, wie das wir bisher...
Ja, es ist tatsächlich Hipster-Café.
Warum?
Und dann noch nicht mal mit einem MacBook.
Also ich meine,
ein MacBook ist das Mindeste, was man braucht,
dass man sich in so einem Café blicken lassen kann.
Nee, nee, das geht nicht.
Okay, was haben wir
sonst noch jetzt zur Ausfall-Video?
Wir haben noch Battlefield-Montage,
das können wir nachher angucken.
Raid Garbage Legends können wir uns angucken.
Ich habe jede Menge Videos
gespeichert für später angucken.
Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt
Raid Garbage Legends an.
Da kriege ich ja auch immer noch fast wöchentlich
irgendwelche Mails,
ob ich nicht Werbung
machen möchte für den Crap.
Und ich habe die mal gefragt,
ganz am Anfang, ganz am Anfang...
Warte mal, ich muss mich mal kurz einloggen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das
genau ging.
Ich kann euch die Antwort mal vorlesen
von der Marketing-Frau,
was
die da für zuständig ist.
Ähm...
Ich muss mal kurz
raussuchen.
Partnership, bla bla bla...
Raid, Raid, wo ist das denn?
Das ist schon ein bisschen
her.
Ich find's, ich find's nicht.
Ne, das ist schon zu lange her.
Es ist ein tolles
Handyspiel, bla bla bla, genau.
Was habe ich da drauf
geantwortet?
Die waren richtig
planlos.
Ich find's nicht.
Leute, ich find's nicht mehr.
Die haben zumindest sinngemäß, ich habe die gefragt,
so nach dem Motto, ja, wie finanziert sich
denn das Game, wie sieht's mit Ingame-Shop aus?
Und, ähm, wie, also mit
Ingame-Shop und Währung, wie ist das Spiel
so aufgebaut? Und dann hat
die geantwortet, ich versteh nicht, was du mit
der Frage Ingame-Shop meinst.
Da hab ich auch grad,
Alter, wisst ihr
überhaupt, was ihr da verkauft?
Das war so fail.
Richtig pepega,
ja. Woher kommt
eigentlich die PR-Kohle?
Ne, von den Spieleherstellern.
Oder, wo die Spielehersteller
das Geld für die PR können.
Wahrscheinlich von ihrem Publisher oder
von der Firma, denen das gehört.
Warum spackt,
warum spackt denn das Fullscreen
in letzter Zeit so rum?
Was ist denn das?
Warum spackt das Fullscreen so rum?
Forget everything you knew about
honesty and integrity, because one of the
most ambitious mobile games of 2019
has just been released.
Leg das, leg das, leg das an diesem Plugin an.
Introducing Raid Garbage Legends.
Playing Raid is the least immersive thing possible.
We even made a button, so the game plays
itself and you actually...
Leg das, leg das an diesem...
Ah!
Forget everything you knew about honesty
and integrity, because one of the most ambitious
mobile games of 2019 has just
been released.
And it's gonna change literally nothing.
Introducing Raid Garbage Legends.
Playing Raid is the least immersive thing possible.
We even made a button, so the game plays itself
and you actually do nothing, because that's
totally what you love about RPG video games.
It can only really be compared
with the biggest PC and console titles,
which is a complete lie, but that's okay,
because you can literally compare anything
to anything else if you want.
Die haben dick aufgetragen in der Mail, ja.
Jennifer Love Hewitt doesn't make it accurate,
but rest assured, Raid definitely
isn't a trashy mobile cash grab.
It's really just as good as major PC
and console games, for sure.
I wouldn't lie about that for money, no way.
In all seriousness, today,
I'm just gonna rip on Raid Shadow Legends,
because it's trash, and the marketing for it
is trash, and it's annoying, and I'm sick
of seeing it...
Sick of the emails and sick of the money
being offered with the clear expectation
that I will regurgitate this disgustingly
awful sales pitch, which is full of lies,
by the way, for a game I absolutely
despise, to trick my own audience
into spending money.
Pretty much anyone who watches YouTube
should know what Raid is. It's a turn-based
mobile game, and it's probably one of the most
prolific YouTube sponsorships out there
on the entire platform, with hundreds of...
Das stimmt, das stimmt, ganz ehrlich,
so einen riesen Marketing-YouTube-Geschiss
und auf Twitch habe ich selten gesehen
wie bei diesem Spiel.
Es gibt ja kaum Channels, die nicht
dafür geworben haben.
Also, es gibt gefühlt mehr Channels,
die dafür geworben haben, als Channels,
die das gleiche Skript lesen.
Skillshare, ja, okay,
Skillshare, was haben wir noch,
CreateCoursesPlus, Audible ist auch gut dabei,
aber das da ist wirklich,
vor allem bei Gaming-Channels,
ExpressVPN, ja, die machen auch gut Werbung,
aber von der Anzahl her
ist das alles, glaube ich,
verschwindet das gegenüber
das, was die hier marketingtechnisch auf YouTube
veranstalten gerade.
Sogar Dance Gaming hat
das bei sich gehabt.
...
Das Game sieht ultra langweilig aus.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist das Werbevideo und das ist das Spiel, was am Ende rausgekommen ist?
Moment.
Das Video von dem wir schwer angucken über das andere, äh.
Ah, dann nicht verlinkt, okay.
Hahaha, das hat ja mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ist das nicht irreführend, wenn das interessiert? Die Hersteller doch nicht.
Ist das, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie geklaut aus, aus, ähm, Monster Hunter oder aus, aus Scalebau und was sie rausbringen wollen oder irgendwas, aber.
Ja.
Ist das nicht irreführend, wenn das andere, äh.
Ich bin jetzt mit, momentan.
Beide dieser Agente haben mich weiterhin für Raid Shadow Legends gesendet, auch wenn ich jetzt die neueste Agente zweimal gesagt habe, dass Raid nur das eine Sponsorship ist, das ich nicht mal hören möchte, weil es ein automatisches Nein ist.
Im Grunde genommen wird Raid mich nicht allein lassen, und ich bin sicher, dass das gleiche ist wie viele andere Kreatoren.
Also, anstatt einfach diese Verlust zu verhindern, werde ich dir jetzt alle verschiedenen Gründe sagen, warum du nicht spielen sollst.
Irgendwie 좋아 fort Kh molten du Raid Shadow Legends.
Habe, ähm, Martin, hatten wir auch schon, kennst du noch das China-Overwatch?
Kann sich noch jemand an das China-Overwatch, an, als in China-Overwatch-Klon erinnern.
Hier, das da.
Hallo alle! Willkomm.
Willkommen zurück in ein anderes Schmuck im Neubau, das ist, das ist das eine.
Bop.
Moment mal, das meine ich gar nicht, das meine ich gar nicht!
Das meine ich, das ist, das ist das Falsche.
Solcher Serfentieserfn, das meine ich gar nicht!
Ich meine, die haben auch krass geklaut.
Aber das meine ich gar nicht.
Das da meine ich.
Legend of Titan.
Genau, das meine ich.
Genau, die sogar Tracer gerippt haben direkt.
Das meine ich.
Das war ein übelst Fail.
Die kennen da nichts.
Und ich meine, ähm, was?
Dann juckt die das mit der Werbung erst recht nicht.
Overwatch hat nur von Team Fortress geglaubt.
Dann zeigt mir mal Tracer in Team Fortress, Alter.
Der Scheiß macht echt Kohle, ne?
Das dachte ich mir schon.
Aber man muss halt sagen,
ähm, ich kann jeden verstehen,
der sagt,
gib mir 4000 Euro, ich mach Placements für Raid.
Also man ist ja fast schon blöd, wenn man es nicht macht.
Also ich kann das verstehen,
dass man es macht, ja?
Also ich würde es nicht die Leute verurteilen,
die das machen.
Das ist halt...
It's money.
Wenn ich mir schon überlege,
was die rausrücken für so ein Ghost Recon Video,
wenn ich da mehrfach...
Werbung machen würde für so ein Crap-Game,
ich meine, die müssen ja mehr bezahlen,
weil sie wissen, dass es Crap ist
und abzocke für die Leute.
Ähm, also muss die Leute quasi mehr bestechen,
dass sie das machen.
Ich kann es keinem übel nehmen, der es macht.
Ich muss für die Uni C++ lernen.
Daher wollte ich fragen,
kannst du jemanden, der die Aufgabe für einen machen kann?
Ja, du solltest sagen, du willst...
Naja, das kannst du nicht sagen, aber...
C++ ist...
Hast du verloren jetzt.
...
Wollte gerade sagen, geh zu Fiverr
und such dir irgendeinen Fiverr-Inner,
der für dich C++ programmiert.
...
PC- und Console-Games.
Really, it's just flat out wrong.
The combat is just turn-based clicking,
even though they say thrilling on more than one occasion.
Don't get me wrong, that can't be true.
Die schwätzen ja alle viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Something like Slay the Spire is amazing
and it's actually the subject of my next Indie-Spotlight-Video
for anyone that's curious,
but that game has so much more depth
than Raid ever could or ever will.
It's frankly staggering.
Das soll ja auch keine Tiefe haben.
Das soll jeder Casual-Bob kapieren.
Und vor allem soll jeder Casual-Bob kapieren,
dass er an der Stelle nicht weitergeht
und dass er sich jetzt was kaufen muss.
Der Friseur spielt jetzt auch
ein AFK-Game.
One of the most ambitious RPG-Projects of 2019.
Oh ja, unbedingt.
Da können alle anderen RPGs einpacken, wenn ich das sehe.
In their own words.
That is from this right here.
One of the previous briefings I was sent by Raid.
Last time I touched on this subject,
I blurred some info to make it not a direct attack on Raid.
Truth be told, I want more sponsorships on this channel.
I'm not actively trying to burn bridges,
but I can't seem to get away from them
and they suck, so I've stopped caring.
This very deliberate script leaves,
absolutely no room for...
Warte mal, warte mal.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz gucken, was da drin ist.
Please make a reaction scene, 5 seconds, using game intro.
Die haben aber schon sehr genaue Vorstellungen.
Kein Wunder, dass die dann zusätzlich,
weil sie wissen ja, dass sie ein Skamars-Spiel sind,
dass sie noch zusätzlich mehr Kohle abdrücken müssen.
That's all features you expect from Brand New...
Amazing story!
Haha!
Ja, so sieht das Game aus.
Das hat bestimmt eine absolut krasse Story.
Awesome 3D-Graphics,
giant boss fights,
pee-pee-pee...
Okay, war's vielleicht wirklich?
Amazing storyline!
Da bin das...
Stelle ich jetzt mal so in Frage,
ob's das wirklich hat, ja?
Ach, das ist, was man sagen soll, oder was?
Emotionally with your own opinion,
share your...
Also man soll sagen...
Man soll überzeugen...
Oh, das ist ja richtig.
Das hab ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Das hab ich so noch nicht gesehen, ja?
Also es kommt manchmal vor,
dass sie einem halt gewisse Auflagen machen.
Zum Beispiel möchte er,
den Video nicht, dass man AMD erwähnt und sowas.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Ähm, aber das ist, das ist echt schon...
Also so im Detail hab ich's noch nicht gesehen.
Dass jemand wirklich einen Satz für mich reinschreibt,
den ich sagen soll.
I never expect to get this level of performance
out of a mobile game.
Also dass da direkt ein Satz drinsteht,
den ich sagen soll,
ähm, das hab ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Look how crazy level of detail is on these champions.
Haha!
Ja.
He's getting big real fast, so get in early.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Crazy prices.
Clan-ID.
Alter, die ziehen aber echt alle Register hier, ha?
Haha!
Also, in der, in der umfangreich,
ähm,
in dem Umfang,
ich hab die Mail nicht gefunden,
Easykiller.
Ähm, sonst hätt ich auch die Antwort drauf gefunden.
Ich such, ich such noch mal.
Ich such noch mal.
Raid.
Raid wants to sponsor your video.
Raid wants to sponsor one of your videos.
Raid.
Oh, die sind aber hartnäckig.
Die haben schon noch öfters, noch öfters gespammt.
Die E-Mail ist langweilig, die die geschrieben haben.
Die letzte.
Das ist, ist sehr, ist halt,
da gibt's nix Großartiges zu zeigen.
Die schreiben,
Good morning MaxFPS.
I'm Valentina from WQ
and one of my clients.
My client is Raid Shadow Legends.
You should know the game
because it's everywhere on YouTube.
Ja.
Das ist so.
Das ist, die Mail ist langweilig.
I hope we can work together.
Nope.
Wie geht's mit der Schienawage voran funktioniert?
For a creator to be themselves.
None.
They tell you exactly how to compose the segment.
And because of that,
the blame is shifted from inaccurate representation
of a product by a creator
to self-serving, fully cognizant,
predatory advertising by a major mobile developer.
Now, over time, it looks like they have learned a little bit, at least.
It's slow.
It's painfully obvious that they aren't very bright over there,
but they have at least learned something because the show,
the game on mobile device.
Ja, bla bla bla.
Du kriegst sogar auch alles an Videofont schon fertig.
Seemingly overhauled a little while ago for a bit more freedom
given to the individual creators to say a word here and there
that wasn't dictated to them verbatim.
Good job, Raid.
Gold Star.
But with that in mind,
I think it's even more important to tell you all the reasons
not to support this game,
because it went from being a brain dead meme
where the same awful script was everywhere
to being just individual enough
where it will probably now fool a lot more people.
Raid claims to have an amazing storyline.
And again, most people promoting this game
probably just use the stock footage
and installed it for 20 seconds to get the rest of what they need.
It's understandable.
No shade.
That's exactly what I would do, too.
But if you actually try to play this game for the story,
it's a brutal disappointment.
It makes no sense.
It has no good cutscenes.
It's just a trashy mobile game like any other.
But this one flippantly claims amazing storyline.
To go further, the game crashes constantly.
Amazing storyline, ja.
But it's not crashing the few times
because there was really...
Tim, bloß hat euch Coin Master getoppt.
...way too many crashes.
It's in your face worse than almost any other game
I have ever played in my entire life
with the pop-up ads and the money grubbing.
It's constant.
And referencing back to the Let's Go Whalers,
where the CEO of a mobile game development company
pointedly discussed how to manipulate free users
into a cycle of detrimental spending,
it is exactly that to the letter.
Raid is one of the most installed games on the Google Play Store.
Warum hat das so viele gute Bewertungen?
Gold star again, I guess.
You have two gold stars now, Raid.
But when you surf the reviews,
it gets really, really hard to believe that these are legitimate.
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also komm, Leute.
Wenn einer, wenn ein Hersteller
einem
Creator
4K Plus gibt,
dann kaufen die sich auch Bewertungen.
Das ist doch, das ist doch mal, also,
also, sagen wir mal so, 4K Plus ist ja nicht das Problem,
aber 4K Plus plus diese Vorlagen,
dann kaufen die sich auch Bewertungen.
Das heißt, die haben Kohle
und die haben da auch keinerlei Hemmungen.
Zeig mal, was haben, was schreiben die da?
Was, was schreiben die Leute denn?
This game good!
Graphics!
And many characters!
Ah, yes.
I love games.
Since I was a kid.
So I like to play
Adelf.
What?
Hahaha.
I want.
Was?
I want skip.
I may attack
and win fast.
My time is little for game.
Please insert skip 10 rounds.
Attack.
Ah, yes.
Ähm.
Exquisite review.
Epic! Brilliant!
Hahaha.
Das ist, der geht aber ab.
Brilliant! Epic!
Ähm.
Okay, das ist die einzig echte.
Oh, oh, der hier ist gut.
Old man.
I have waited, was?
I have waited to play this game for some time now.
A crappy phone.
Aha.
Let me tell you, I love this game so much.
Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich.
Oh man.
Legit. Alles legit.
Ach, positive Bewertung im Store und du bekommst in-game was.
Ach so.
Ja dann.
Ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Quasi best...
positive Bewertung in-game quasi zu forcieren?
Ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Aber Google wird das ziemlich wurscht sein,
weil die Dinger bringen wahnsinnig viel Kohle.
Another variation on that kind of simplicity.
Ich verdiene ja Transaction mit.
Because one of the primary tactics now in mobile games
is to offer a reward in the app.
Okay. Good game, just
lots of fun, great.
Unable to install.
Hahaha.
Das ist scheiße.
For a five star review.
I don't see that exact pop-up in my own playtime,
but I would wholeheartedly believe it's there.
The much more interesting thing is that the negative reviews
very often seem to have a common thread,
which is pay to win.
Raid is a gotcha RPG to its very core,
and it also has PvP
as one of the primary advertised features.
With its genre identity considered,
the PvP is blatantly and horrifically
pay to win.
This title is advertised as free to play,
which is true, I guess,
but it's not free to play in the same way as Path of Exile
or Warframe. Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Path of Exile, da muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
Werbung für machen. Path of Exile hat
das beste und fairste
Free-to-Play-Modell von allen Spielen.
Es gibt kein besseres.
Und auch kein besseres
Game in der Richtung.
Path of Exile ist das beste
Action-RPG und hat das beste
Free-to-Play-Modell.
Ich sag nicht, dass andere auch schlecht sind.
Kann durchaus sein, dass sie ähnlich gut sind.
Habe ich nicht gespielt.
Aber gerade im Action-RPG
Segment ist Path of Exile
das beste Spiel mit dem besten
Free-to-Play-Modell.
Wie macht Path of Exile das?
Eigentlich, indem sie gar nichts Großartiges machen.
Du kannst
das komplette Spiel
genauso spielen,
wie es der Hersteller gedacht hat.
Und auch alle, die reincachen,
müssen das Spiel so spielen, wie es der Hersteller gedacht hat.
Das einzige,
was du halt machen musst,
in Anführungsstrichen in Path of Exile,
wenn du das wirklich aktiv spielst,
ist
Inventarplätze
kaufen.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass du nicht spielen kannst,
ohne Inventarplätze.
Nacholibre, 6 Monate,
Dankeschön. Huge Sub.
Also es ist nicht so, als könntest du nicht spielen.
Du hast erstmal genug Stash-Plätze.
Aber sobald
du ein bisschen höherer
Content bist und viele Items
hast und viele Drops und auch ein bisschen was
zählen willst, ist es auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt, sich neue
Inventarplätze, also Kistenplätze
zu kaufen. Aber man muss sagen,
ich hab mir, ich hab ja das schon vor
ähm
vor Jahren
damals schon gekauft, ja. Und ich muss sagen,
Path of Exile ist eines der
Free-to-Play-Spiele, wo ich
absichtlich und gerne
mir Sachen gekauft
hab.
Weil das Spiel gut ist und das Spiel auch fair gemacht ist.
Und es ist besser als jedes andere
Action-RPG zurzeit.
Es ist einfach
eine Art
Spiele-Spiele, die
sich hinter den Loot-Packs
oder Loot-Packs verliehen.
Path of Exile hat sehr kleine kosmetische Loot-Package.
Das ist wahr. Aber das ist nur ein kleiner
Subset der Kosmetik. In Warframe
haben die Entwickler tatsächlich eine
randomisierte Loot-Option entfernt, weil die Spieler
es zu viel verwenden und es mit ihren
Spielen zu verwenden.
Das ist
ähnlich wie Diablo, nur viel, viel besser.
Und viel
tiefer
von der Komplexität her,
von dem, was du alles machen kannst. Viel tiefer
als Diablo.
9x Fatal,
7 Monate, dankeschön.
8x
9x
Also kriegst du ohne Probleme an einem Tag Level 40 und die Hälfte der, ungefähr die Hälfte der Main-Story durch.
Na klar, was sonst?
Ich kann dir was empfehlen, Herz93.
Story Guide?
Ja, nimm dir den Guide hier.
Ich habe jetzt ja auch wieder neu angefangen.
Nimm dir den Guide hier und spiel die Story nach dem Guide durch.
Wohlgemerkt, wenn dich die Story nicht interessiert.
Wenn dich die Story interessiert, ist natürlich das nicht die beste Möglichkeit.
Aber der sagt dir genau die Schritte, die notwendig sind, was man mindestens machen muss und vom Ablauf her recht optimal ist, um die einzelnen Acts nacheinander durchzuspielen.
Guck mal, das ist Akt 1.
Das dauert, keine Ahnung, 45 Minuten oder so, wenn man das hier nachspielt.
Ich glaube, Akt 4 oder so war, glaube ich, der längste.
Oder was, Akt 3?
Nee, Akt 3 ist, glaube ich, der längste.
Da muss man ein bisschen was machen.
Aber wenn das...
Wenn es hier nach dieser Geschichte durchspielt, ist es wirklich Iza-F.
Story Skippe.
Ja, nimm dir den Guide hier.
Das ist top.
Du machst hier so gut wie keine Nebenquests.
Also sprich, wenn du Nebenquest-Geschichten brauchst, wie Skill-Resets oder gewisse Gems oder die ganzen zusätzlichen Labyrinth-Herausforderungen, Belohnungen, da musst du die noch nachher machen.
Aber nach diesem Guide bist du halt sauschnell auf einem höheren Level.
Und hast die Main-Story ganz gut durch.
Kommt dann nicht der nächste zweite Teil?
Ja, aber das machen die auch wieder ganz cool.
Path of Exile 2 ist im Prinzip Path of Exile 1 plus neue Kampagne und ein paar neue Sachen.
... für Advertising.
Die meisten von ihnen, außer aus grundsätzlicher Bedürfnis oder vielleicht aus Unverständlichkeit für die Industrie.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Faktoren.
Und wiederum muss ich klarstellen, dass es nicht mein Platz ist, die Individuen zu attackieren, die dieses Spiel promoten.
Auch wenn ich es in manchen Fällen möchte.
Aber es ist mein Platz, die Firma zu attackieren, um eine riesige, uninspirierte...
Und wenn ihr, wenn ihr eine Noob-Klasse spielen wollt in Path of Exile, macht es so wie ich.
Weil ich habe ja auch erst wieder angefangen.
Spielt irgendein Noob-Summoner-Bild.
Es ist nicht umsonst so, dass glaube ich 28% aller Charaktere in Path of Exile in der aktuellen Ladder sind Witch und spielen irgendeine Form von Beschwörer.
Das ist mega langweilig, aber um erst mal zu starten und Kohle zu machen, ist es gut.
Wobei, so langweilig ist das gar nicht. Ich meine, du musst ab und zu mal zumindest deine Skelette nachcasten, ja?
Ja.
Not only would it destroy my credibility, since half my channel is based on criticizing anti-consumer practices,
it would just ruin the experience for me and I'd quit very soon after.
I want that $4,000 from Raid.
And believe me, it's nothing compared to what they are giving most other creators who accept the deals.
In the past I accepted certain sponsorships right as I started out that I probably shouldn't have, but I was just happy to have them at all.
Ireez, ich hab da sogar ein Video zugemacht.
Ein gesponsertes Video.
Ich... Mir hat's nicht gefallen.
Okay, also Fazit ist, man kann sich schon denken, das Spiel sackt und das Spiel sackt auch wirklich.
The email will be down below in the description.
When it's a good product from a good company,
I will give you the most genuine,
genuine praise and endorsement imaginable, I promise.
But if it's a bad game or company or whatever,
I'm not gonna say it's good just for money,
because that doesn't work out well and everybody suffers.
Weil Raid halt, ne?
If you want support in this kind of action support,
it will allow me to not care about these monetizing issues,
or whatever it is, all the COPPA stuff,
or subject the videos to sponsors like Raid,
there are links in the description.
Aber ich meine, diese Stage kann man sich doch 15 mal angucken.
Guckt euch mal dieses massive detail an diesem,
dieses Tor an und ich kann nicht glauben, Leute,
wie gut die Performance ist und wie hoch detailliert die Models der, der Helden sind.
Unglaublich und diese, und diese Geschichte.
So, jetzt machen wir Sponsor. Easy.
Gib, gib 4k. Gib Geld.
Sieht aus wie Woe Classic, ne? Woe Classic sah stimmiger aus.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Das da, Battlefield gucken wir gleich noch.
Remember Assault Kills für die XWTF.
Der Flight Simulator, oh, das wollte ich mal angucken, ja, ja.
Der, der Flight Simulator, den gucken wir mal gleich.
Ähm, ich muss mal kurz, Leute, ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Bin gleich wieder da, aufs Klo.
Äh, MacDuffel hab ich, ich bin mir aber gar nicht mehr ganz sicher, welches das war.
Ist es das MMO mit Permadeath?
Ich bin mal kurz pinkeln.
So, wieder auf dem Start.
Ihr könntet doch auf dem Klo weiter kommentieren.
Ihr könnt das auch sein lassen.
Ähm, okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was es Neues zum Flug, zum Flight Simulator gibt.
Früher haben wir da immer noch so richtig, so richtig uncool dazu gesagt, Flug Simulator.
Aber nein, Flight Simulator.
Bestelle ich mir dann auch bei Amazon.
Und spielens unter Ubuntu.
Erstmal ein bisschen Tee einschenken noch.
Während ein paar Glückliche schon an den ersten Alpha-Tests für den Microsoft Flight Simulator teilnehmen können,
müssen sich die meisten noch auf die Beta und den offiziellen Release der wunderschönen Flug-Simulation gedulden.
Inoffizielle Videos oder Infos aus der Tech-Alpha
solltet ihr auch nicht erwarten.
Denn wer derzeit schon spielt, darf keine Videos oder Infos daraus veröffentlichen.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht jede Menge Details und Videos zum neuen Flight Simulator gibt.
Herr Schluckstor.
Dieses Video habe ich mir mal das offizielle Material angeschaut, das in den letzten Wochen veröffentlicht wurde.
Es sieht schon gut aus, kann man nix sagen.
Ähm.
Übrigens, was man hier sieht ist,
dass das Berechnen von Terrain aus den Satellitenbildern nicht immer so gut funktioniert.
Wenn ihr euch die Häuser da teilweise anguckt oder die viereckigen Bäume,
das sieht nur aus einer gewissen Höhe gut aus.
Aber da kommt bestimmt noch ein bisschen was.
Aber ich sag mal so perfekt wie echt wird es natürlich nicht aussehen.
Ich fasse auch Details, eindrucksvollen Detailinfos zusammen,
die Microsoft und das Entwicklerteam von Asobo bislang gelassen haben.
Also bringt eure Sitze in eine aufrechte Position und genießt den Flug.
Ich garantiere euch, ihr werdet am Ende da sitzen und sagen,
das kann doch einfach nicht sein.
Fangen wir mit der Welt an, denn die ist ja der Spielplatz,
den uns der Flight Simulator mehr oder weniger vor die Füße legt.
Ob das nun die natürlichen Wunder der Erde sind
oder eindrucksvolle vom Menschen erschaffene Bauten,
ob nun die Freiheitsstatue oder der Eiffelturm.
Aber die Welt ist verdammt groß und um sie im Spiel darzustellen,
Um sie im Spiel darzustellen, braucht man unglaubliche Datenmengen.
Was ich cool finde, dass sie sogar Verkehr und so simulieren in den Städten.
Also sprich, wenn man jetzt über Frankfurt fliegt, sieht man da sogar Autos rumfahren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man Fußgänger sieht, aber Autos rumfahren, LKWs.
Wir kommen im Fall vom Flight Simulator aus den Kartendaten von Microsofts Suchmaschine Bing.
Die zwei Petabytes an Daten umfassen Infos zu den über zwei Millionen Städten der Erde.
Höhen-Daten an Daten umfassen Infos zu den über zwei Millionen Städten der Erde.
Höhen-Daten, Straßen und Daten zu allen Flughäfen der Welt, was wohl über 40.000 sind.
Dabei betonen die Entwickler, dass es auf der ganzen Welt möglich sein wird, nach sich zu fliegen,
weil man die markanten landschaftlichen Merkmale gut genug erkennen wird.
Solche Merkmale können Städte oder Flüsse sein.
Was das in der Praxis heißt, ist gut.
Das geht nicht, da kann man nur Naruto-Run reinmachen.
Dass jeder Spieler als eine der ersten Amtshandlungen im Flight Simulator den eigenen Heimatort überfliegen wird
und nachschaut, ob er seine Nachbarschaft aus der Luft erkennen kann.
Satellitenbilddaten allein reichen aber für die Welt im Flight Simulator nicht aus.
Und hier kommt die Cloud-Berechnung über Microsofts Assured Cloud ins Spiel,
die beispielsweise für die Platzierung der Bäume in der Simulation zuständig ist.
Über die Cloud werden aber auch ganze Gebäude prozedural ergänzt, wenn es keine anderen Daten gibt.
Das sieht nicht so hundertprozentig richtig aus hier.
Das sieht irgendwie nicht so ganz echt aus, ja?
Das sieht so ein bisschen sehr blockmäßig aus.
Ja, ich rede gar nicht von den...
...wie den Grundriss der Häuser gibt.
Zudem gleicht das System schlechte Datensätze aus,
beispielsweise wenn Gebiete in den Satellitendaten...
Echt? Okay. Chat, ich glaub's euch.
...die Cloud-Berechnung bedeutet aber auch, dass...
Twitch-Chat-Cloud in 2K20. Ich glaub, es geht los.
...die Daten immer gestreamt werden müssen.
Nun hat aber nicht jeder eine gute Internetleitung oder überhaupt immer eine Internetverbindung.
Um dieses Problem zu lösen, überprüft das Spiel zunächst mal, wie gut die eigene Leitung ist
und passt dann die Menge der übertragenen Daten an die Leistungsfähigkeit der Verbindung an.
Das heißt aber auch, mit einer besseren Leitung bekommt man mehr Detail.
Äh, Uwe, ähm, Rob-Uwe, gar nicht.
Haha, das ist das Problem. Das sind so die kleinen, das sind so die kleinen Probleme, deswegen sag ich auch immer,
die Leitung auf dem Desktop hat so seine Problemchen.
Es gibt Patches für, es gibt Patches für, glaub, Firefox oder Chrome?
Chrome. Für Chrome, für Chrome gibt's, ähm, wenn du, wenn du Arch drauf hast, kannst du dir Chrome installieren.
Chrome mit, äh, GPU Acceleration. Gibt's ein fertiges Repo.
Für Firefox ist mir nix bekannt. Chrome funktioniert aber.
...Hals.
Und ja, ich geb dir recht, es ist der Witz, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Sowas müsste mit Abstand die höchste Priorität bei allen Browser-Entwicklern haben.
Ist halt lächerlich, ja, hast du voll und ganz recht.
...in allen Gebäuden, Flüssen, Seen und Meeren.
In einigen Regionen gibt es sogar die Daten für die Platzierung der Bäume.
Flug nach Sicht ist also auch in der Offline-Version möglich.
Oder soll es zumindest sein, denn bislang sind das natürlich Aussagen der Entwickler,
die wir noch nicht überprüfen konnten.
Wer ohne Internetverbindung trotzdem noch die höchste Qualität der Spielwelt erleben will,
kann vorher ausgewählte Regionen auch vorladen und auf dem eigenen System speichern.
Hier mal ein paar Beispiele.
So sieht die Seattle-Region im Offline-Modus aus.
Und so sieht Paris im Online-Modus aus, wobei hier ein Großteil der Gebäude...
Ähm, wie wär's, wenn ihr, wenn sie uns die Seattle-Region offline und online gezeigt hätten und nicht, äh, also, ne?
Nein.
Weil so schlecht sieht das auch nicht aus.
Aber trotzdem nicht ganz so gut.
Aber trotzdem, das kannst du überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
...Offline-Modus aus.
Und so sieht Paris im Online-Modus aus, wobei hier ein Großteil der Gebäude über die Cloud generiert wurde.
Einen Schritt weiter auf die höchste Qualitätsstufe geht es in New York,
wo für die Gebäude auch noch Fotogrammetriedaten vorliegen.
Oh.
So wie für 400 andere Städte im Flight Simulator.
Da können wir was anverfliegen.
Es werden auch viele Kleinstdetails der Welt prozedural erstellt.
Dazu zählen Details wie...
Super, Grobi, installier FFZ und du kannst alles einstellen.
Ich hab in FFZ jegliche Overlays ausgestellt für Twitch, weil es mir immer auf den Keks geht.
Ich hab auch keine, machen sie jetzt hier ihre...
Du kannst in den Settings, du kannst alle Overlays ausstellen.
Ach, du meinst das Picture in...
Nee, ach, du meinst unten in der Leiste.
Oh nee, das glaub ich nicht, dass man die Player, die Videoplayer-Bar...
Ähm...
Oh, das glaub ich nicht, dass das geht.
Ich hab überhaupt kein Picture in Picture.
Zeig mal.
Twitch.
Äh, ähm...
Guck mal.
Wie das mich findet.
Wie das mich auf Twitch findet, Google, Alter.
Wie es mich einfach findet, obwohl ich hier ganz anders heiße.
Das da?
Ja, das ist doof.
Das ist doof.
Ja, das ist wirklich blöd.
Da klickt man aus Versehen drauf.
Wie Dreck, Asphalt, Wassereffekte inklusive von winderzeugter Wellen,
Nachtstraßenbeleuchtung, Details an Gebäuden und Gras.
Auch wenn ich keine Ahnung habe, warum man in einer Flugsimulation
überhaupt einzelne Grashalme anzeigen muss.
Aber hey, es sieht schon toll aus.
Es sieht, äh, äh, äh, 2D aus vor allem.
Wenn man sich das hier mal genau anguckt.
Es ist ja gut, es sind halt Bilder, ja.
Und auch die Bäume sehen sehr platt aus.
Aber ich mein, hey, man ist ja nicht hier, sondern da oben irgendwo.
Für ne Flugsimulation.
Das ist doch sehr nice.
Ein wichtiger Aspekt für jede Flugsimulation ist natürlich das Wetter.
Auch wenn die Simulation davon aufgrund von technischer Beschränkungen lange eine
große Herausforderung war.
Für die neuen Flight Simulator wurde eine komplett neue Wetter Engine entwickelt,
die alle Lichtquellen zusammen berechnen kann.
Dazu zählen Sonnenlicht, Mondlicht, das Licht der Sterne und das Licht der Städte
auf der Erde.
Und das wird dann nochmal von atmosphärischen Faktoren beeinflusst,
beispielsweise der Luftverschmutzung.
Ja, sieht aus wie Windows XP hinterher.
Die Schattenberechnung ist ein Wechselspiel der Quellen.
Hohe Berge sollen Schatten auf Wolken werfen.
Wolken werfen Schatten auf den Boden und auf sich selbst.
Sogar die einzelnen Wolkenschichten werden Schatten aufeinander werfen,
woraus dann wiederum der Schatten berechnet wird, der auf die Erde fällt.
Zudem gibt es volumetrischen Regen und volumetrische Regenbögen.
Soll heißen, diese Effekte sind nicht flach, sondern dargestellt.
Auch die Regentropfen auf den Windschutzscheiben der Flugzeuge werden möglichst realistisch berechnet.
Abhängig von der Geschwindigkeit der Maschine.
Und wenn man hoch genug fliegt, bildet sich sogar Eis auf dem Flugzeug,
das man dann an den Scheiben oder in der Außenansicht auch auf dem ganzen Flugzeug sehen kann.
In diesem Timelapse-Video sieht man die verschiedenen Effekte in Wechselwirkung.
Der 3D-Regen, der volumetrische Nebel,
Ob das jemals so rauskommt, müssen wir halt mal gucken, ne?
Die Beleuchtung der verschiedenen Wolkenschichten und das Sonnenlicht,
das durch ein Loch in den Wolken, die tieferen Wolken,
und den Boden anleuchtet.
Und hier sieht man auch mal den Regenbogen.
Und gleich sehen wir die Wassertropfen.
Und wer jetzt schon denkt, die sind doch wahnsinnig,
dem kann ich nur sagen, das ist noch gar nichts.
Sogar der Sonnenstand ist abhängig von der Jahreszeit
und verändert sich im Laufe des Jahres.
Auch die Position des Mondes und der Sterne wird realistisch dargestellt,
egal wo ihr auf der Erde herumfliegt.
Und wie dieser Zeitlapse-Clip zeigt, beleuchten die Lichter der Städte sogar die Wolken,
die darüber hinweg gleiten.
Das gilt übrigens auch für das Wasser, das ebenfalls die Lichtstrahlung
Was brauche ich denn da für einen Rechner für?
bei schlechtem Wetter auch deutlich dunkler dargestellt wird,
als an einem schönen Sonntag.
Ja, choose my name, du hast schon recht.
Also grafisch kann das gegen Raid Shadow Legends natürlich einpacken.
Und die epic, brilliant Storyline ist natürlich auch nicht zu vergleichen.
Ich kann mir wahrscheinlich gar nicht vorstellen, wie oft ich beim Zusammenschneiden dieses Videos
jetzt schon zum Kollegen Obermeier gesagt habe, das ist einfach unglaublich,
was die da machen, aber der Irrsinn hört nicht auf.
Hört euch mal an, wie die volumetrischen Wolken berechnet werden.
Die bestehen nämlich aus bis zu 32 Schichten, vom Meeresspiegel bis in extreme Höhen
und werden permanent von verschiedenen atmosphärischen Faktoren beeinflusst,
unter anderem natürlich auch von Windströmungen.
Dieses System soll es ermöglichen, jede Art von Wolken, die es in der Natur gibt,
auch im Spiel darzustellen.
Unterstützt wird das Ganze durch eine Sichtweite von 600 Kilometern.
Wenn man in die Wolken selbst hineinfliegt, ändert sich auch die dargestellte Dichte
und dieses Video hier zeigt wieder mit Zeitbeschleunigung,
wie Aufwinde an den Bergen sich auf die Formationen der Wolken auswirken.
Da der Flight Simulator am Ende aber natürlich auch noch ein Spiel sein soll,
könnte er die Wetterpresets jederzeit im Flug ändern, von klarem Himmel bis zu Unwettern.
Das Ganze gilt auch für die Tageszeit, an der man frei dreht.
Wer das Wetter aber nicht manuell einstellen will, kann dem Spiel auch sagen,
dass es Wetterdaten von überall auf der Welt in die Simulationen hineinladen soll.
Die Daten basieren dabei sogar auf bis zu 60 Wolkenschichten
und auf Angaben für Regen, Druck und Jetstreams.
Die Jetstream-Daten sind beispielsweise wichtig für die Navigationsplanung,
da die Flugzeuge die starken Winde in unterschiedlichen Höhen ausnutzen können.
Für die Berechnung der Aerodynamik selbst
haben die Entwickler den Code der früheren Flight Simulator-Version angesehen
und weitreichende Verbesserungen vorgenommen,
bis hin zur kompletten Neuentwicklung einiger Elemente.
Das betrifft sowohl den Kern der Physikberechnung
als auch die Simulation der einzelnen Flugzeugsysteme.
Dafür wurde sogar eine komplette Simulation der Luftströmung entwickelt.
Eine wichtige Neuerung bei der Physik Engine ist die Unterstützung für schräge Landebahnen
und die Möglichkeit allgemein auf schrägen Ebenen zu landen,
also bei einem Motorschaden auch abseits einer regulären Landebahn.
Damit das funktioniert, wurde unter anderem die Simulation der Reibung an den Reifen überarbeitet.
So reagiert der Gummi jetzt je nach Untergrund anders und laut Aussage der Entwickler realistisch.
Dasselbe gilt für Bodenunebenheiten und die Bremsen der Flugzeuge,
die jetzt dafür sorgen, dass man auch auf schrägen zu einem vollen Halt kommt,
wenden und wieder starten kann.
Eine technische Änderung am Code soll außerdem dafür sorgen,
dass das Spiel immer in einer hohen Framerate berechnet wird,
selbst wenn das System gar nicht so viele Bilder pro Sekunde darstellen kann.
Hä? Soll das funktionieren?
Wie willst du mehr FPS berechnen, als du FPS berechnen kannst? Hä? What?
Es soll dafür gesorgt werden, dass selbst mit niedriger FPS die Simulation weiter realistisch berechnet werden kann.
Achso, die meinen so quasi Delta. Gut, das macht man ja schon seit 20 Jahren.
Eine andere Code-Anpassung soll dafür sorgen, dass sich Flugzeuge,
nicht mehr so stark wie auf Schienen beim Fliegen anfühlen,
denn das System widersetzt sich jetzt nicht mehr so stark den Änderungen der Flugbahn,
wodurch die Flugsimulation selbst ebenfalls realistischer werden soll.
Zudem wurde die Berechnung der Massenverteilung beim Gieren, bei Rotationen und bei Rollen überarbeitet.
Damit man das wiederum im Cockpit besser nachvollziehen kann, wurden auch die Instrumente überarbeitet,
besonders der sogenannte Ball, der anzeigt, in welche Richtung sich das Flugzeug neigt,
oder sogar leichte Parallelbewegungen nach links oder rechts anzeigen kann.
Auch der Treibstoffverbrauch bei unterschiedlichen Höhen wird jetzt korrekt simuliert.
Zudem bekommen Spieler mehr Kontrolle über die Flaps und das Fahrwerk sowie Außentanks werden jetzt als physikalische Objekte simuliert,
wirken sich also auf die Aerodynamik des Flugzeugs aus.
Da die Wolken wie schon gesagt volumetrisch berechnet werden,
simuliert das Vereisungssystem jetzt die tatsächliche Luftfeuchtigkeit um das Flugzeug herum, wie dieser Clip zeigt.
Wer will, kann übrigens auch auf das alte Simulationssystem aus dem vorherigen Flight Simulator zurückschalten.
Für alle, die mal die Unterschiede zum neuen System wollen, ist das sicherlich eine spannende Option.
Und wenn man dann wieder zurück zur neuen Version der Aerodynamikberechnung geschaltet hat,
sitzt man in einem Flugzeug, dessen Oberfläche in tausende Oberflächenbruchstücke aufgeteilt wurde,
auf die die Kräfte der Umgebung wirken, beispielsweise der Wind, die Luftfeuchtigkeit und der Luftdruck.
So kann eine Tragfläche beispielsweise eine Wolke,
Wolke streifen, während auf der anderen Seite Turbulenzen auftreten.
Mit dem detaillierten System ist beispielsweise eine genauere Berechnung von Strömungsabrissen möglich.
Zudem wird jetzt auch simuliert, wie der Luftstrom von der Flugzeugoberfläche differenziert wird,
wodurch hintere Teile der Maschine einer veränderten Strömung unterliegen.
Das wird besonders für Kunstflieger wichtig, die viel mit solchen physikalischen Vorgängen spielen, um ihre Manöver zu fliegen.
Die Luftsimulation beschränkt sich aber nicht nur auf die Flugzeuge,
sondern wirkt sich, wie vorhin schon erklärt, auch auf die Wolken aus und wird weltweit simuliert.
Und nicht, dass sie das verbieten wollen, weil man da drinnen Terroranschläge planen kann.
Heutzutage traue ich ihnen alles zu.
Es ist zum Beispiel auch möglich, die sogenannten Towering Cumulus Wolken zu erzeugen,
die durch starke Aufwinde entstehen und dabei so groß werden können,
dass sie im Inneren die Umfangwinde erzeugen, die in kleinen Maschinen lebensgefährlich sein können
und bei großen Flugzeugen für starke Turbulenzen sorgen.
Und weil das ja nicht schon alles irre genug ist, reagieren die Luftströme auch noch auf die Welt,
also auf Städte, Bäume, Täler und Berge.
So werden in Bodennähe bei bestimmten Bedingungen beispielsweise Turbulenzen erzeugt,
die bei langsamen Flugzeugen für Probleme sorgen können.
In Tälern hingegen prallen Luftströme aufeinander, wie man es hier im Video sieht.
Tja, und diese ganzen Simulationen erleben wir als Spieler natürlich hier, im Cockpit eines Flugzeugs.
In diesem Fall im Cockpit der kleinen Robin DR-400, die lediglich analoge Anzeigen bietet.
Aber selbst hier werden alle Anzeigen simuliert und funktionieren tatsächlich.
Der Spieler kann sogar jedes einzelne Licht im Cockpit einstellen und dimmen.
Modernere Maschinen als die DR-400 setzen auf Glasinstrumente mit digitalen Anzeigen
und Touch-Eingabemöglichkeiten, die im Flight Simulator integriert sind.
Wie das funktioniert, kann man hier sehr gut sehen. Nützlich ist das beispielsweise zum Managen des Flugplans.
Wenn Sie davon aber nicht völlig überfordert sind, soll es jede Menge Tooltipps und Erklärungen geben.
Außerdem kann man entscheiden, wie komplex die Start-Checkliste sein soll oder ob man sie komplett überspringen will.
So sollen auch Anfänger leicht ins Spiel kommen.
Serienexperten werden sich zudem freuen, dass die Entwickler ihr Spiel möglichst kompatibel
mit zusätzlichen Eingabegeräten bis hin zu Heimcockpits machen wollen.
Um die nötigen Schnittstellen auszuprobieren, haben die Entwickler sogar ein eigenes Cockpit.
Da gibt es ja Leute, die haben ihr komplettes Wohnzimmer daher umgebaut.
Bekommt das VR-Support? Das wäre natürlich noch eine coole Sache mit VR, ja.
... im Bordeaux nachgebaut. Das hier sind allerdings keine Szenen aus dem nachgebauten Cockpit,
sondern aus dem Inneren von Flugzeugen im Flight Simulator, die dank aktueller Grafikeffekte
wie Screenspace, Ambient Occlusion, Reflections und 4K-Texturen möglichst glaubwürdig aussehen sollen.
Auf diese Weise sollen im Cockpit die Lichtverhältnisse simuliert werden, die je nach Wetter und Sonnenstand unter Identität,
auch in einem echten Flugzeug herrschen würden.
Damit das alles originalgetreu ist, wurden echte Flugzeugcockpits per Laser eingescannt
und einige Flugzeughersteller haben den Entwicklern sogar ihre 3D-Daten aus der Produktion der Maschinen überlassen.
Ähnlich aufwendig wurden auch die Sounds aufgenommen.
Zudem sorgt ein neues dynamisches Soundsystem für glaubwürdige Geräusche im Cockpit.
Und dank einer neuen dynamischen Kamera, die die Produktion des Piloten simuliert,
und die auf die verschiedenen Kräfteeinwirkungen im Cockpit reagiert,
soll es für Spieler leichter sein, physikalische Flugbedingungen nachzuvollziehen,
auch wenn sie vor ihrem Bildschirm natürlich nichts wirklich davon fühlen können.
Soweit zu den offiziellen Informationen und geplanten Features des Microsoft Flight Simulator.
Wie viel davon tatsächlich so 1 zu 1 im Spiel steckt, funktioniert und auf normalen Rechnern zum Laufen gebracht werden kann,
wird sich im Verlauf des Jahres zeigen.
Eins steht aber schon jetzt fest.
Diese Simulation ist eines der ambitioniertesten Projekte, die ich je gesehen habe.
Aber Microsoft hat zumindest die Kohle und die Manpower so dafür.
... selbst auszuprobieren.
Wenn ihr das auch wollt, geht auf die Webseite vom Flight Simulator und meldet euch dort zum Insider-Programm an
und behaltet die Anmeldeoptionen für die Tests im Auge.
Genau, ich bestell mir dann Threadripper, wenn's rauskommt.
Und das war's von meiner Seite aus.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat und ihr keine weiteren Videos von uns verpassen wollt,
aktiviert doch hier bei YouTube die Glocke.
Ansonsten freuen wir uns natürlich auch über einen Like.
Ich bin schon zwei Stunden on, wir haben erst drei Videos geguckt oder so.
Wie geht denn das?
Das müssen wir erst mal gucken.
Wer ist denn aktuell der reichste? Der Amazon-Dude, oder?
Wie, ist das ohne Sound?
Kann nicht mit Sound.
Das ist der Amazon-Mensch, glaube ich doch.
Musik.
Wir machen mal, Moment.
Der Walmart-Dude, der ist, kann ja mal so weit dabei jetzt, ne?
Auch mal Microsoft, Microsoft.
Irgendein Scheich.
Max, wo bist du denn auf der SSR?
Secret.
Das sind am Anfang immer die gleichen, die sich abwechseln, ne?
Ah, da ist Amazon.
Amazon.
Ikea.
Jawoll.
Alter, die Musik!
Die Musik.
Auf zweifach ist ein bisschen Fail.
Oh.
Wer ist das?
Das ist bestimmt, das ist bestimmt irgendeine, irgendeine mexikanische, äh, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt der Amazon-Typ.
Der steigt jetzt gleich.
Weil ich, der ist, glaube ich, ganz oben, der Amazon-Typ mittlerweile.
Die Walmart-Leute, ey.
Was witzig ist, es war ganz am Anfang, war mal ein Deutscher dabei.
Ähm, irgendeiner vom BMW, glaube ich.
Aber jetzt ist es, mittlerweile gibt es nichts mehr hier.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt will er es wissen, ey.
Hui.
Hat Bill Gates überhaupt noch so viel, hat er nicht alles irgendwie seiner, oder fast alles seiner Stiftung da vermacht?
Aber der hat, der hat ganz gut Money, würde ich sagen.
Was ist 162 Milliarden?
Das heißt, der könnte jedem Mensch auf der Welt 16 Euro geben.
16 Dollar.
Oder?
Wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass es auf der Welt 10 Milliarden Leute gibt.
Ich weiß, es ist, es ist nicht ganz, aber wenn man mal hochrechnet, da könnte 16, 16 Euro, könnte der jedem, jedem Mensch auf der Welt geben.
16, das macht es jetzt auch nicht aus, ob Euro oder Dollar.
Was meint ihr, was los wäre, wenn Raid Shadow Legends so viel Geld hätte?
Die würden, die würden dann einfach mal eine eigene Videoplattform aufmachen mit, mit nur Raid Shadow Legends.
Der hat Kohle, der Dude, ja.
Ihh, Oracle.
Geh mal fort.
Der Zug ist auch am Start.
Oracle.
Hm.
Was gucken wir denn jetzt, Leute?
Wollen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield gucken noch?
Was gucken wir, was gucken wir denn hiervon jetzt noch?
Gaming-PC?
China-PC?
Of Wish?
Shopping im größten Computer-Markt in der Welt.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so spannend.
Dann hast du mal wieder Bock auf YouTube.
Ja, da fehlt mir irgendwie so, so das passende, weiß nicht, passende Anstoß für.
Ey, ich glaube, Hardware-Deals ist langweilig.
Ich habe da vorhin mal drüber geskippt.
Da passiert, da, da passiert gar nicht so viel.
Das ist eigentlich langweilig.
Das gucken wir nicht.
Top 10 Mobile Phone.
Das haben wir doch schon, das haben wir doch schon mal geguckt.
Das haben wir doch schon mal geguckt.
Das ist doch nichts Neues.
Das ist nichts Neues.
Das haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Dann, dann gucken wir jetzt mal.
Dann, dann gucken wir jetzt mal, ob das hier was taugt da.
Hey everyone, we're at the world's largest electronics market.
We are at SEG E-Market in Huaqiangbei in China, which is within Shenzhen, one of the...
Shenzhen?
Ich dachte, es heißt Shenzhen, aber Shenzhen...
Ey, ey, ey, ey, wird sich da wahrscheinlich besser auskennen.
...the largest cities we've ever been in.
What we're going to do is walk through ten floors and try to build a computer.
We're not going for the cheapest build possible.
We just buy an AliExpress and ship it for that.
Instead we are going for the most unique.
So our goals today are to find a very unique case.
We're going to try to find some open-loop watercooling, but we'll see if we have to settle.
And look around for interesting CPUs, maybe X79, old school Xeon, something like that.
So those are our goals.
This place, there's very little English spoken here, at least at a level that you can negotiate...
Ach, das kannst du denen schon irgendwie verklickern, denke ich.
...computer parts...
Das, das wird, irgendwie wird man sich da schon, irgendwie wird man sich da schon verständigen können.
Es geht ja immerhin um Technik.
So, my Chinese isn't great, we're going to do our best.
Uh, wo der Zhongwen Buhao, as you'll hear me say, potentially a lot in there.
Uh, but I can say things like, we are building a computer.
We're in Sichuan, Yitai, Diannau, and we are looking for watercooling parts.
Something very specific that I learned.
We'll see if I learned the wrong phrases for 40 minutes on the plane.
Let's go inside, look around...
Ach, Wasserkühlung will er auch noch bauen.
...in Huaqiang Bay SEG.
Before that, this video is brought to you by...
...by GIGABYTE's X570 Master Motherboard.
The X570 Master is what we use for all of our Ryzen 3000 CPU reviews...
Oh, Qt Chat ist unterwegs.
Ayaya!
...this strip of Huaqiang Bay is a small part of a massive shopping district.
Although Shenzhen is often associated with factories,
the city is now slowly transitioning to accommodate some higher-end commerce and more service economy jobs.
In fact, most of the factories we toured told us that finding workers in Shenzhen has become challenging...
...as...
...there are, probably not enough workers.
...that maybe don't want to live the factory life that their parents did.
As these factories creep further and further out...
...we are no longer keen to use it.
We are no longer keen to work without getting kicked out of the foundation
because we have to work so slowly.
Of course, the less we want to work that people aremoreки
we arethon Brighton Bay,
we can leave grip
...and already seek automation to replace a dwindling supply of workers.
Huaqiang Bay has sprung up with a mix of high-end, legitimate retail stores
mixed with grungier wholesale fronts,
AliExpress-Beste.
Das wird erstmal verhaftet, weil er gefilmt hat.
Ich meine, je nach Stadt ist 140 Dollar nachts nicht viel, aber 140 Dollar ist schon ordentlich.
Wisst ihr, was ich lustig finde?
In China ist das so, wenn ihnen heute einfällt, so nach dem Motto, oh Mist, wir brauchen einen neuen Stadtteil,
oder so, oh Mist, wir brauchen einen neuen Flughafen, dann stürmen da irgendwie erstmal die nächsten eineinhalb Jahre irgendwie 350.000 Leute hin und werkeln da rum und nach zwei Jahren ist es fertig.
Wir brauchen 40 Jahre.
Okay, übertrieben, 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre.
Aber ich bin froh, dass in China auch so sinnlose Kunstdinger überall stehen haben.
Da frage ich mich auch immer bei uns, was genau, was sollen solche Dinger?
Was sollen solche Dinger sagen?
Gut, ich meine, in China ist es wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht so schlimm, wenn beim Bau des Flughafens dann ein paar Leute sterben.
Ja, dann kriegen dann die Familien einen Brief heimgeschickt, so nach dem Motto, er ist für das Vaterland gestorben, er ist ein Held, oder was weiß ich, was sie sich da so schicken, keine Ahnung.
Gut ist, wenn hier beim Umbau Leute sterben, ist das wahrscheinlich kritischer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es in China so ist.
Zumindest eins ist Fakt.
Die kriegen solche Sachen schneller hin als wir.
Haben die jetzt nicht den größten Flughafen der Welt irgendwie in kurzer Zeit, ein paar Jahren aus dem Boden gestampft?
Das ist ja cool.
Sowas suchst du hier, sowas suchst du hier vergebens in Deutschland, zumindest in Frankfurt.
Einen Shop, wo du dir Teile kaufen kannst und die du sogar eben dran dann quasi auf einem Board löten lassen kannst.
Das ist cool, das ist richtig nice.
Die Elektronikshops hier wissen gar nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Also die Komponenten sind halt Modelle, die hier rettet, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten, Komponenten...
Das ist richtig cool.
... also nicht direkt so ein Deal wie, dass sie direkt in eine Fabrik gehen, man könnte Service-Mount Komponenten an der SCGE-Markt kaufen, um
auf ihrer SMT-Line 10.000 Euro zu installieren.
Das place macht am besten, um schneller zu machen und die Produktion zu beraten, aber es hat auch eine Community, auf der wegschneidend
einzeln von jedem spezialisierten Verkäufer zu verbanden.
Kannst du mal kontaktieren, die Sachen auch, SMD, ihr auf, aufs Board quasi, nicht löten, schmelzen lassen?
Boah, hier, huge Chinese skills.
Cool, Matt.
Es sieht aus, es sieht eigentlich, es sieht aus wie ein Mülleimer, wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Es sieht aus wie ein Mülleimer und es hat auch einen Griff oben dran.
Guck mal.
Es sieht schon aus wie ein Mülleimer.
Vor allem hier oben auch mit einem Mülleimer.
Vor allem hier oben auch mit dem Deckel, den man aufmachen kann.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Mülleimer, wo so ein Fuß, wo so ein Fußding ist, wo man drauf treten kann.
Und dann dreht sich das oben so auf.
Nee, das sieht aus wie so ein Mülleimer mit so einer Fußbedienung.
Kennt ihr das? Wo man unten so auf den Hebel drückt und oben geht es dann auf.
So sieht das aus.
Oder ein Wasserkocher.
Könnte auch ein Reiskocher sein.
Ja, das haben wir uns letztens angeguckt, Easykiller.
Und auch RGB-LEDs.
Der Bargain-Prozess war...
Oder den Staubsaugerbehälter.
Ich will in den Kühlschrank kommen.
Kühlschrank.
Ich bin noch nicht da.
Englisch ist hier nicht sehr normal und mein Chinesisch ist nicht sehr gut.
Wenn ich es vorher denke, können wir mit der Hälfte der Gespräche sprechen.
Aber die Antwort braucht jemanden, der sehr patient und langsam spricht und sehr einfache Wörter benutzt.
Die meisten von den Hagglingen sind...
In der Realität sieht es so aus.
Wenn keiner von euch so gut spricht, wie die anderen, dann ist das, wo...
Deuten.
Zeigen.
Aufmalen.
Man kann sich...
Man wird sich da schon...
Es geht ja um Technik.
Man wird sich da schon irgendwie einig.
Man muss, glaube ich, aufpassen, irgendwelche Gesten zu machen, die hier verbreitet sind, aber dort jemand versteht.
Wisst ihr, zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier fragen würde, so was kostet's, dann würde ich so Zeigefinger und Daumen zusammen reiben.
So hier so.
So wisst ihr, so.
Was kostet's?
Es kann durchaus sein, wenn du in einem anderen Teil der Welt bist, dass diese Geste heißt, ähm...
Fick deine Mutter.
Oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ja?
Und im Zweifelsfall kriegst du...
Hast du dann richtig Probleme.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Das kann...
So manche Gesten können echt in die Hose gehen, wenn man woanders in der Welt ist.
Es ist nicht ungewöhnlich, dass Leute aus überall im Weltraum so kommunizieren, wie es bei der SEG E-Market ist.
Einige Apps funktionieren in den meisten Fällen gut.
Komplexe Szenen werden von Verkaufsverbrauchern verursacht, und die Apps verursachen oft Szenen, die man aufbauen kann, aber einfache Szenen sind ziemlich einfach.
In diesem Fall, nachdem wir beide durch unsere Telefone gezwitscht haben, hat sie uns gesagt, dass sie in den Warehouse gehen müsste, um ein Zettel zu holen.
Ach, das ist, das ist, äh, äh, Plastikverpackung.
Oh, okay.
Ähm...
Ist es in diesem Gebäude?
Hä?
Ähm...
Isch a funnie.
Hat gut geschmeckt Zeichen?
Was ist bei dir das gut geschmeckt Zeichen, wenn du so, so Hand an den Mund machst, so, oder was?
Oder, oder was meinste?
Was ist das jetzt gut geschmeckt Zeichen?
Daumen hoch, oder was?
Äh.
So diesen, wenn du so, ach so, okay, ach du meinst hier das, so dieses Taucher-Okay-Zeichen da, ach so, ja gut, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das Aufforderung ist, ne, dazu, passt ja auch irgendwo.
Für einen.
Die hat damit gerechnet, die kaufen jetzt 50.
Da kriegst du ja fast ein schlechtes Gewissen, wenn du nur eins kaufst.
Ich find's ja schon mal cool, dass die weiß, wie man dieses Gehäuse auseinander macht und bedient.
Das würde heute 99% der Mediamarkt- und Saturn-Mitarbeiter wahrscheinlich überfordern.
Ja, sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie Plastik, aber es könnte durchaus klar sein.
So we didn't want to haggle too much on the price.
They were polite and patient, and instead we asked to see a few of the 120-Millimeter-Fans to make it a bit more worth their time.
Of course, some things transcend language barriers and require no translation.
Oh, das ist aber, das ist aber enttäuschend, no RGB.
Ja, Leute, no RGB.
Ehrlich, das ist so ein Ding, da würd ich auch gerne mal durchlaufen und mir angucken.
Alter, muss ich erstmal ein bisschen abnehmen, weil in China wirst du bestimmt, wenn du zu sehr Kokona aussiehst, Chap angeguckt.
Die sind alle so schlank da.
Ja, erstmal kurz 2000 Lüfter kaufen.
Da könnte ich endlich mal noch ein bisschen mehr USB-Sticks und USB-Kabel kaufen.
M50 ist ja viel zu wenig.
Ja, das ist so ein Ding, da würd ich auch gerne mal durchlaufen.
Partly because they were his display units, but also because he wanted to move volume.
We tried asking several times if we could just buy one or two, but he always pointed us back to the catalog and waved us off.
Knowing now that he'd have to run to a warehouse just to make the maybe six US dollars that these are worth, it sort of makes sense.
It's just, it's not worth his time.
Ja, aber gehen da so viele Leute hin und kaufen irgendwie erstmal 30 Lüfter?
Negotiating and just offer a good price.
I'll just make an offer, I guess.
How should I offer?
For 10 bucks, 15?
15 might be kind of high, but let's try it.
Well, we'll gain the Ibai Kuai.
Okay?
Ibai Kuai, could you mark?
Ich find's cool, dass er so weit Chinesisch kann, dass er sich damit verständigen kann.
Fehlen da nicht die Stecker?
Naja, also je nachdem für was.
Also ja, schon, wenn du es direkt irgendwo dranstöpseln willst.
Aber je nachdem, vielleicht willst du, was du dran machen willst.
Also die Stecker.
Die Stecker kannst du dir da auch im Tausender-Pack für 5 Dollar kaufen.
Because this is a sample.
He's trying to say to buy it from the factory.
Will you so please?
Beide stehen so mit Translator da, übelst geil.
To me, it won't work.
Guck mal, er steht mit dem Translator da und das ist so geil.
Aber Leute, was ich halt cool finde, die geben sich da richtig Mühe.
Das würdest du hier in einem Saturn- oder Mediamarkt überhaupt nicht erleben.
Der WeChat.
Natürlich.
Ich mein, die müssen schon mitlesen können, was der Verkäufer schreibt.
Erstmal hinkwischen, Kameras.
Well, the Chinese is not good.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay?
In Wirklichkeit denkt er sich gerade, okay, dann ist er endlich weg.
Okay.
We handed over about 15 US-Dollars to make this easy.
He didn't take issue with that offer and we thought it might be on the high side.
But we also just wanted to buy the fans and move on to other booths.
For us, this was a good deal.
A lot of people get hyper-focused on haggling when they see these types of videos.
Posting as armchair experts in the comments about how we could have gotten something for cheaper.
But keep in mind that we're inconveniencing someone with general ignorance of how things work,
limited language abilities, a camera in their face, and then asking to buy one.
Of a low cost item.
And of course, this is all while the guy is trying to take a lunch break, too.
So to us, 15 dollars was fair for all the trouble and we seemed happy with it.
Sure one walks away with what they wanted.
These aren't for our main PC build from this trip, but we do intend to put them to use.
We needed to find some more parts for the actual computer.
Looking around, we found some cool decommissioned Intel dual socket motherboards and tried to get a good deal on them.
But the pricing just didn't work out.
After accounting for the higher end CPUs worthy of these boards,
the total cost of two CPUs on a motherboard, dual socket, would have been about 900 dollars.
USD, not RMB.
Which is way beyond our budget.
At that price, we really might as well just buy some modern...
Hä? Was? Das hab ich grad nicht gecheckt.
Äh, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, so, also von, von...
Sind das 8-fach Slots?
PC 8-fach, what the fuck?
Das sieht fast aus wie ein Server Mainboard.
Auch von, auch von, auch von dem...
Die sind halt...
Server Mainboards sind halt immer so bewusst nicht fancy gemacht.
Achso, das ist ein LGA 2011, okay.
Two CPUs on a motherboard, dual socket, would have been about 900 dollars.
USD, not RMB.
Which is way beyond our budget.
At that price, we really might as well just buy some modern hardware in the US.
And so, we gave up on these options.
Instead, we returned to the shop where we bought a cheap X79 motherboard back in March.
The shopkeepers remembered us, so getting a good deal wasn't too hard here.
We got an Intel E5-2670 Z-Hardware.
A 2670 Xeon CPU from about 2012, which is an 8-core 16-thread part at 3.3 GHz boost frequency.
And then we coupled that with an interesting TG-X79-V309 motherboard.
Searching for this product strain...
Kriegst du deine Dinger ohne Verpackung?
Wie, oder?
Taobao and Alibaba seemed to indicate that this was an OEM motherboard at some point.
It's not a good one, but that's why we liked it.
It's just sort of strange.
We noticed that some of these same model motherboards had differently colored SATA connectors.
Some a mix of red and black.
Some just black.
Some blue.
Ja, da kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Ich meine, wer braucht schon einheitliche, einheitliche Connectors?
Ja, das ist doch vollkommen overrated.
Da kann man ruhig mal einen schwarzen Controller draufmachen.
Einen roten, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Sie schaut mich... Ja, sie schaut uns an, Leute.
... transparent 24-pin headers.
This seemingly totally random selection of small parts on top of the same motherboard
gave us confidence that we found the right product.
The form factor isn't quite micro-ATX.
And not quite mini-ITX.
It might be...
Das ist China-Format.
... call this mini-DTX, which is a slightly longer form factor than mini-ITX.
Mini-DTX? Hab ich noch nie gehört.
... and the same width as mini-ITX.
It's also incredibly uncommon.
The biggest name that's doing a mini-DTX board is probably the Asus Impact for the new Ryzen 3000 series CPUs.
But beyond that one, it's unlikely you ever really hear about this...
Hab ich doch...
... and never heard about mini-DTX.
... also bought two sticks of ECC 8GB memory...
Ich kann mich noch an BTX erinnern.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht dieses Telekom-BTX, sondern BTX, was sie verentwickelt haben, Intel damals, weil die CPUs zu warm wurden.
... heard CL11, and this is DDR3 as a reminder.
This allows us to populate both DIMM slots on the motherboard, but we're still obviously losing two of the channels on the 2670 CPU.
It's a four-channel capable CPU, but we have two DIMM slots on the board.
So, yeah, it's not a good build, but that's sort of the point.
It should be fun, and again, a bit weird.
The total cost of the motherboard, the former 8-core high-end Xeon CPU, once priced at $1550 US when it launched, and the 16GB of RAM wasn't too bad.
The X79 board was 300 RMB...
Kann das sein, dass der SATA rot ist, weil der auch Strom integriert hat?
Es gibt doch manchmal so SATA-Dinger, wo man quasi so mini...
... quasi so mini SATA-DOM-Sticks reinstecken kann für VMware oder so.
Die sind manchmal rot.
Nee, SATA ist da nicht.
Gaming SATA-Port, genau.
Aber die Verkäuferin ist schon niedlich gewesen, also...
Wenn da nur so Leute Mainboards verkaufen...
Das allein schon da einen Grund, quasi sich 15 Mainboards am Tag zu kaufen.
... würde es 58 Dollar kosten.
Und die Motherboard würde es ungefähr 51 bis 60 Euro pro Stück kosten, wenn wir 100 davon gekauft hätten.
Wir konnten nicht das exakte Board in einer Einheit finden.
Aber auch dieser hohe Preis ist ähnlich wie das, was wir bezahlt haben.
Wenn wir diese Teile online bestellen wollten, kosteten wir etwa 144 Dollar.
Also waren wir ziemlich auf dem Mark für die Preise.
Ich meine, auf dem Mainboard ist nicht wirklich viel drauf, ne?
Ich meine, immerhin ein 16-fach...
Ob der wirklich 16-fach ist, weiß man nicht so genau.
Und einen Gaming SATA-Port.
Wie gesagt, wir haben nicht wirklich so hart gehackt, weil wir schon...
Audio, ja. Ja, ja, hier irgendwo.
Es hatte, glaube ich, Audio.
...
Versteckt er sich gerade?
Hat er sich hinter der Säule versteckt?
...
wie zum Beispiel der mittlere Kühler-Master, die geschlossenen Kühlschritte,
Standard-Tower-Kühlschritte, viele Kühler-Master-Sachen.
Aber wir wollten etwas mehr Uniquentes.
Es war ein wenig schwer zu kommunizieren, dass wir Open-Loop-Kühlung wollen,
aber wir haben es schließlich herausgefunden.
Wir sind in Shui Lan,
in Weng Bu Jian, Shui Lan.
Ich finde das so cool, dass er das in Chinesisch mit denen hinkriegt.
Shui Lan, Shui Lan.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
120.
Main-Buy.
Main-Buy, 120.
Main-Buy, 120, okay.
TDP für CPU.
Für den分離.
Für den分離 Shui Lan.
Ja, einfach mal Yes sagen.
Einfach mal Yes.
So einfach.
This one?
Ja.
Einfach.
Nein.
Okay.
Einfach.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wir haben dann über Google Translate nachgefragt,
ob irgendwo im Gebäude Open-Loop-Kühlung gibt,
aber er sagte Nein.
Wir haben sogar Linus' altes Video angeschaut,
mit seltsamen Teilen,
in dem die Paare versuchten,
mehr als einen einzigen Open-Loop-Kühlschrank
im ganzen Mall zu finden.
Letztendlich haben wir uns entschieden,
einen 120 Millimeter-Aero-Kühler zu kaufen,
mit einem Drogon auf dem Kühlschrank.
Das kann nicht da rumgehen,
weil ein 15-Jähriger wie ich
das Kühlschrank für ein System-Bilder
lieben würde.
Wenn in China ein Drager auf dem Lüfter ist,
dann muss das was taugen.
Das kostet auch 1.000 Dollar.
Das ist gut unter dem Preis
deines mittleren, günstigen 120-Millimeter-Kühlschranks
auf Newegg.
Aber ob es gut ist,
ist eine andere Geschichte.
Wir haben den Thermal Paste Shop nicht gefilmt,
oder nicht viel davon,
aber unser nächster Schritt war,
einen Thermalkomponent für unseren neuen Computer zu finden.
Gibt es da auch welche,
wo man sich dann den PC zusammenbauen lässt?
Also, ich laufe durch das Haus
und lasse mir alle Teile geben,
und dann gehe ich wohin
und lasse mir den zusammenbauen?
Das wäre doch mal was.
Stimmt, ja.
Denke ich auch.
Wir haben uns zu einem dunkleren Bereich
eines leeren Untergrunds
um unseren Tim Dealer zu finden.
Zuerst haben wir uns für einen einzigen Kühlschrank gefragt,
aber der Verkäufer schluchzte
und schlug seinen Kopf.
Und dann haben wir uns gefragt,
wie viel das für einen Kühlschrank ist,
was definitiv nicht schrecklich klingt.
Aber sie hat uns gesagt,
dass es 5 Dollar US-Dollar kostet.
Nachdem wir das gehört haben,
haben wir uns gefragt,
ob es eine bessere Modelle gibt,
und sie hat uns die Gold-Tübe ausgesucht.
Die HY-510-Modelle von Thermal Breeze
kostet ca. 4 Dollar US-Dollar
für eine 30-Gramm-Tübe auf Amazon,
und wir haben uns einen ganzen Kühlschrank gekauft
aus dem 1,9-Meter-Kelvin-Komponent
für 5 Dollar.
Ja gut,
warum solltest du ja auch
eine einzelne Wärmeleitpaste kaufen,
wenn du das für 5 Dollar kriegst?
Wir haben uns dann
die HY-610 gekauft.
Die HY-610 kostet 3,05 Watt
pro Kelvin.
Das könntest du ja in Frankfurt
am Hauptbahnhof verkaufen.
Die müssen ja nicht wissen,
dass da Wärmeleitpaste drin ist.
Nur bestes Zeugs aus Shima.
Noch nicht toll,
aber besser,
wenn wir den Zahlen vertrauen können.
Und wir haben uns...
Aber ich weiß nicht,
was passiert,
was passiert eigentlich,
wenn man sich Wärmeleitpaste spritzt?
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gesund, hä?
... 5 30-Gramm-Tübe
plus ein paar kleinere Tübe
für ca. 10 Dollar US-Dollar.
Dann wird's cool.
Das wird's sein.
Das ist quasi so,
so wie bei Witcher.
So irgendwelche Mutationen.
Also du tunest dich quasi dann
mit Wärmeleitpaste
und schwitzt dann nicht mehr so schnell.
Wie bei Bioshock.
RAM-Star.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Dieses Logo sieht voll China-mäßig aus, oder?
So eine rote Faust,
das passt einfach voll gut zu China-Hardware.
Oder generell zu China.
Das passt einfach.
Nur um nicht zu sagen,
mit die Faust aufs Auge.
... Name,
that both screams quality.
After a few vendors told us not to film
and another refused to sell us this model,
we finally found someone willing to part
with his beloved RAM-Star SSD
at 240 Gigabytes
and accompanied with a genuine RAM-Star foil sticker,
so we knew it's not...
... counterfeit.
... we...
... knew we were finally in for a good SSD.
The drive cost us 120 US.
We tipped the guy because we did actually...
120 für 200, das ist aber ganz schön teuer.
... warehouse and spend 30 minutes
finding one of these drives that we so desperately wanted
and we only wanted one of them.
To be clear, this is probably total garbage as an SSD,
but it looked different.
We found one of these drives sold in the US for 56 dollars,
which is quite some markup,
but it was the only site we could find selling it.
Oh.
Stimmt, das Video... Ach, das Video ist schon ein halbes Jahr alt. Ja, aber selbst da...
Ich denke, die Leuchtenplätze sind für einen 2080 Ti etwas beginners.
Wir haben uns erst einmal festgestellt, dass wir einer Leuchtenplatte absolut nicht interessieren
Okay, das ist da anscheinend teurer.
Eine NES-TV-Gaming-Konsole, die aussieht wie eine PlayStation.
Only in China, only in China, ey.
Das bestimmt absoluter Crap.
Hot.
Der Dragon-Kühler, ja.
Wo ist jetzt der fertige PC?
Da, da, keine Ahnung.
Fand ich echt, ich fand das wirklich interessant.
Das ist so ein Ding, das würde ich mir live auch gerne mal angucken.
Das würde ich mir auch live.
Das würde ich mir auch live gerne mal angucken.
Follow-up-Video, ja, gute Frage.
Sehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ne, das war was anderes.
Ja, übrigens, Leute, schön, dass so viele dabei sind.
275 Leute gerade, die zugucken.
By the way, übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit kann ich euch ja gerade mal was erzählen.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, was ihr Tolles machen könnt mit eurem Amazon Prime-Account?
Ihr könnt euren Amazon Prime-Account mit Twitch verknüpfen
und könnt dann einmal im Monat einen Streamer eurer Wahl
mit einem Tier-One-Sub.
Das bringt alle Vorteile für euch, von Custom-E-Modes bis zu Badges
und auch alle Vorteile für den Streamer, also eigentlich das Beste für jeden, ja.
Huge-Brain-Aktion.
Einmal Sellout pro Stream muss sein.
Kostet euch natürlich gar nichts.
Gibt ganze vier E-Modes bei mir.
Dann muss ich wenigstens keine Raid Shadow Legends Promotion machen.
So, komm, Leute, wir machen das jetzt so.
Ich bin jetzt schon, ich bin jetzt 2 Stunden 45 on.
Ich muss noch mal aufs Klo.
Irgendwie, ich hab zu viel Tee getrunken.
Ich weiß, ich war erst vor einer halben Stunde, aber es ist, ich muss.
Es drückt.
Und dann gucken wir uns noch mal eine Runde Battlefield an
und vielleicht noch was anderes.
Mal schauen, ich geh jetzt aber erst mal aufs Klo.
Ich bin echt ein Marketing-Opfer.
Ja, das ist doch, das ist doch perfekt.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Besser bei mir Geld ausgeben als bei Raid Shadow Legends, sag ich da mal.
Okay, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Kurz pinkeln gehen.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
So, gucken wir uns noch mal eine Runde Battlefield an.
Ich hab noch kaum Gaming-Zeug heute geguckt.
Ist das überhaupt ein Battlefield-Top-Place, was ich da angemacht hab?
Schreckt.
Was ist eigentlich mit den Fiverr-E-Modes?
Ich sag dazu mal nur...
Ich sag dazu nix.
The main thing.
Weil alles, was ich sage, kann gegen mich verwendet werden.
Moment, das ist gar kein Top-Play.
Nee, das ist doof. Ich will im Top-Play gucken.
Ich will kein...
Kein random Geschwätzegucken von dem Typ.
Okay, gehen wir einfach mal ein bisschen zurück.
Natürlich...
Also, die Commentary-Geschichten von dem find ich nicht so tolle.
Auch, auch was er...
Äh, hier.
Auch was er bei den Battlefield-Videos immer erzählt, ist sehr generic, ja?
Ist, ist, ist sehr generic.
So, so immer, immer, immer das gleiche, so nach dem Motto...
Äh, mit dieser Waffe wird...
Was, was, was sagt der denn immer so?
Ähm, das ist auch eine Waffe, die man nicht so oft sieht, aber trotzdem, äh, nichtsdestotrotz, ein nicer Killstreak.
Irgendwie sowas. Sagt der immer.
Immer.
Das ist das gleiche Zeug.
Ähm...
Flex Press?
Ähm, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
IQ steigt hier wieder ins Unermessliche heute.
Ich muss mein Sellout besser integrieren und öfters machen.
Wichtig.
Oh.
Guck mal, der Sibaro. Der Sibaro hat ein Clip.
Ach nee. Sibelo. Nicht Sib... Fast. Fast.
Ich hab gedacht, dass... Ich dachte, unser cute Mod hätte nen Clip eingereicht, ja.
Die Gegner sind wieder so planlos!
Oh, aber... Oh, nice!
Aber da... Das war cool!
Das war... Das war richtig nice, ha?
Jo, Max, YouTube ist RIP, oder wie?
Warum? Warum sollte... Warum sollte YouTube RIP sein?
Ich hab jetzt zwei Monate an YouTube RIP.
Ich hab jetzt zwei Monate am Stück viel Videos gemacht und da vorne ein Jahr nicht.
Also, das ist genauso wenig RIP wie vorher.
Der Clip war wirklich... Der war... Aber der war richtig geil.
Den muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Das hier geht ja noch. Aber die Headshots mit der Mag...
Das... Das... Ey...
Da... Nice! Nice!
Also das gefällt mir echt gut.
Falls du Cod Top Plays brauchst.
Äh...
Wieso, Eax? Hast du ne Montage gemacht, oder was?
Die gucken wir uns an.
Oder... Ach, du meinst für die Videos.
Ach so, ja. Da hab ich ja...
Da hab ich ja schon. Fast.
Das war richtig cool.
Also die Headshots waren schon geil.
Gut, die sind immer noch... Er hat dann auch Glück gehabt.
Die Gegner müssen dann sowas mitspielen, ne?
Die sind schön reingelaufen. Aber trotzdem, war schon cool.
Aber ihr habt gesehen, er musste kaum wirklich aimen für die Headshots.
Die sind einfach hingelaufen, aber...
Trotzdem, war cool.
Das war echt cool.
So.
So. So. So. So.
So. So. So. So. So.
So. So. So.
So. So. So. So. So. So. So. So.
So. So.
Let's go Bloodzone!
일단, also, ich hab ihn auch bevor mögen.
Warte mal an, was denn so auf dieser Seite.
Was war denn da mit 24?
Wau, was hätt der da wohl der thinker der sich ran gemacht?
Was auch immer so vorgestellt.
Ja.
Aber danke, wir haben zumindest irgendwie mehr die W той.
Achtung.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich hatte auch immer Farbenblit-Modus
im Battlefield an. Oder im Battlefield 4.
Das fühlt sich halt cool an.
Das fühlt sich halt so nice an in dem Game,
wenn du mit der Schneider die Leute wolltest.
Alter, sag mal, sag Gegner.
Gegner, was ist mit euch falsch, Gegner?
Was ist mit euch falsch?
Was ist mit den Gegnern falsch im Kopf?
Haben die irgendwie
ihr Hirn abgestöpselt, einmal rumgedreht
und wieder eingesteckt oder was? Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Oi!
Three-Head. Die Gegner, ja.
Siehst du, Leute, ich hätte schon längst Pistole gespielt.
Weil ich gedacht hätte, ich hätte den nächsten schon eh nicht.
Aber, also,
dass er das eben überlebt hat,
sagt schon alles über die Qualität der Gegner, ne?
Guck mal,
das, nicht die Gegner.
Und warum überlebt er das?
Der Typ, was ist mit denen los?
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Was zum Teufel ist mit den Gegnern los?
Da sind halt nur Noobs unterwegs.
Ich glaube gar nicht mal.
Ich meine, eigentlich müssen die Gegner
doch anteilmäßig in den alten Battlefield spielen,
die die besseren Leute,
also prozentsatzmäßig
die besseren Leute sein, oder?
Weil da halt auch sauviele noch da sind,
die halt irgendwie schon 50 Milliarden Stunden drin haben.
Und halt nicht fünf spielen
oder eins oder so.
Warum ist der runtergehüpft?
Der hätte doch genauso gut von oben runterschießen können,
wäre überhaupt kein Unterschied gewesen, oder?
Ich meine, nur, also, also ja, schon von der Entfernung,
aber nur, dass er schlechter getroffen werden konnte oben.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass das richtige Camper sind.
Das sind einfach Kacknoobs,
die nicht wissen, was sie machen.
Und Kacknoobs campen halt gerne,
weil es sie geistig nicht überfordert.
Das Schiff sieht den auch nicht.
Was ist mit denen los?
Haben die alle die Maus abgestapselt?
Oh.
Mit der Schneider trifft er nicht,
aber so einen random Pistolen,
Schuss, der erhittert, ja.
Das kann auch, kann auch Scamast sein, ja.
Ja.
Der sagt echt jeden Clip das Gleiche.
Die Musik.
Spaß.
Was, ne Range?
Bringt das eigentlich wirklich was in Battlefield?
Ich hab mich da nie näher mit beschäftigt.
Hat das in diesen Teilen wirklich was gebracht,
dieses Reinscopen, um Spread zu vermeiden?
War das wirklich ein Ding,
oder war das eher so ein, so ein...
Ich fühle, dass es besser hittert.
Und noch Legehände gemacht.
Ja, mit Slug, mit Slug gibt's ja kein Spread.
Also in Bad Company 2 auf der Konsole
hat das funktioniert mit dem Reihenzoom.
Dass man quasi Auto-Aim bei den Snipern hatte,
das war halt extrem unfair.
Aber da...
Warum sacken, warum sacken eigentlich
die letzten zwei Battlefields so?
Ich würde echt gerne mal wieder
ein ordentliches neues Battlefield spielen.
Die Gegner sind halt einfach wieder absolut...
Messer ihn doch.
Die Gegner sind einfach richtig brain-dead wieder.
... für more popular in BF3,
because obviously it was a vanilla map.
But still, we're gonna see a return to this
in some respect with Battlefield 5,
when we get access to Operation Underground,
which is coming relatively soon
in the grand scheme of things.
Ah, die Gegner!
Ah, mein Gott, seid ihr blöd!
Seid ihr doof!
Ah!
Sag mal, kommt da nicht einer mal irgendwie
auf die glorreiche Idee, hier außen rumzulaufen
oder sowas? Irgendwas?
Oder über Range den mit der Assault-Rifle
da zu bashen? Irgendwas?
Ja, man, der sieht die noch nicht mal!
Was ist mit denen los?
Was zum Geier ist mit den Gegnern los?
Spielen die alle über Stadia, oder wie?
Du kriegst normalerweise die Shotgun-Ammonie leer.
Ha, ha, ha!
Die Gegner!
Der Wahnsinn!
Das war aber halt das Geile in Battlefield in den Teilen,
dass du immer mal wieder solche Aktionen hattest.
Jetzt ist er ein bisschen greedy geworden.
Ja, das hast du gemerkt.
Battlefield 4, Siege of Shanghai
und ein Attack-Push von Extrems.
PS3-Grafik.
In der Mutter aller Infanterie-Farming-Vehikel
ist es die Amtrak.
Manchmal bekommt diese Sache einen schlechten Reaktion,
weil 1. sie ist langsam,
2. sie ist nicht manövrierbar,
und 3. mit 6 Leuten drin,
das heißt, du bist ziemlich das Ziel
für ein Feind-Vehikel
oder ein glücklicher Ingenieur-Spieler.
Das heißt, Extrems macht es funktionieren.
Er und sein Fahrer
drücken sich auf dieses Objektiv,
um alle zu zerstören.
Die Grenade, die Granaten in Amtrak waren schon echt geil.
Damit konntest du wirklich auffarmen ohne Ende.
Und dann die HMG-Maschinen-Gun.
Ein wirklich cool Clip.
Der ist nahe zu dem, was wir sehen.
Im, den Amtrak?
Die Noobs, die Noobs in Battlefield 3
haben den Amtrak immer gerippt in der gegnerischen Basis.
Dabei gut platziert,
da konntest du die so raussprengen, äh...
Und das Ding hat auch ordentlich was ausgehalten.
Ich glaub 4 oder 5 Raketen.
Ey, wenn die jetzt noch den Panzer killen, ne?
Weh, machen sie nicht.
Sag mal, hat der Blur an?
Seh ich das richtig?
Na gut, halt Playstation.
Das war PC?
War das eben echt PC?
Das sieht, das sieht aus wie auf dem, auf dem 3DS.
Was hat der für Sound-Settings?
Only Bass.
Bass-Boost.
As I said, we drop back and take a look at another few clips from Ascend Uji.
One or two of these don't have audio in the background, which is a shame,
but they are really satisfying.
This FYJS sniping clip on Operation Metro.
People forget this part of Metro on Battlefield 3.
Behind, I think they actually had an LAV on this part of Rush on Metro
back when the game was released.
Nein.
And that is pretty cool.
In der Alpha hatten die einen LAV auf dem...
Das kam nie ins fertige Gelb rein.
...up nearly 1400 points.
Moving on.
An 8-Man with an L96 on Rogue Transmission.
What do you think of Rogue Transmission?
I think it's one of the best maps in the whole of the world.
Wie war eigentlich für dich der Übergang von 360 auf PC?
Kein Ding.
...for a little bit of balance.
Man arbeitet ja auch so am PC und hat jeden Tag eine Maus in der Hand.
...perfect, but overall it's what defines Battlefield in my opinion.
Big, open spaces.
This one.
Being on TDM, I believe, is not exactly a typical Battlefield All-Out-War-Experience,
but it is pretty fun.
A Battlefield All-Out-War-Experience.
Alter, hat er sich den Satz in ihr Marketinghandbuch geholt?
That was a nice streak.
Finally, a satisfying 11-Man with the L96, aggressive recon on Operation Locker.
Damn.
Ha, ha, ha.
Ja, das war schon nice.
Am besten war das C4, das C4 rumspringen und werfen in Bad Company 2.
Da konntest du das C4 ja über drei Kilometer werfen.
Und generell war das Sniper übelst OP.
In der Ecke ist es grün, ist mir nie aufgefallen.
...Abogandis next.
This is Firestorm.
Battlefield 4.
Oh, Playstation 3.
...All-Out-War.
I love this map.
...moments like this, I just have to...
Ich weiß nicht, es sieht, es sieht, es sieht, auf jeden Fall, nee, das ist für PS3, da sieht's hoch.
Jo.
...gar so crappy aus.
Holy shit.
Next up a clip from iDriverJetter.
Not sure if this guy has a YouTube channel, he didn't send one, but I'd love to see some more Attack-Hully clips from him.
This is a super satisfying long-range tow-missile on the enemy attack chopper.
Ah, cool.
Squirrel Slayers next.
This is Operation Locker once again in hardcore mode of all things and a nice flank.
Had to include it because I feel as if...
...there are a lot of hardcore...
...Hardcore fans out there.
...I'm not really one of them, if I'm honest.
...huge console aiming.
...but some of you guys are and you like watching this sort of stuff, so include it for that reason.
Oh, ja gut, auf Hardcore geht das natürlich ab.
Da ist Kripp.
Was ist, was ist mit dem los?
Was, was ist mit dem hier?
Pass mal auf, der Typ der links, der links, der gleich rauskommt.
Was?
Alter!
Was ist mit dir los?
Hahaha.
Hopefully you enjoyed this week's Top Plays.
If you did...
Der ist komplett lost, ja.
...let me know what you think of the episode.
I love Battlefield 3, I love Battlefield 4, and I love watching all of these clips.
Damn.
Thanks for watching and I'll catch you in the next episode.
Gibt's auch Battlefield Hardline Top Plays?
Das ist ne gute Frage.
Weiß ich nicht, ob's das gibt.
Ja, anscheinend.
Aber drei Jahre her.
So Leute, ich geh Mittag essen.
War schön, dass ihr alle am Start wart.
Heute richtig viele Leute wieder dabei.
Ein nicer Aufwachstream.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, weil ich mein, heute ist ja schon Sonntag.
Gibt ja nicht viel andere Möglichkeiten als nächste Woche.
Vielleicht morgen, aber auf jeden Fall alle, alle, alle, alle spätestens nächsten Sonntag.
Aber ziemlich sicher auch zwischendurch.
Und ja, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.